TO I'M JUST REMIND FOLKS OF
SOME OF OUR- RECEDING SEER. IN
THE COMMITTEE AT AS YOU KNOW-
THAT IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT OUR PUBLIC AND
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. WE
ARE STILL ARE TRYING TO LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING FACE
COVERING THAT- GUIDELINES.
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. SO TO ALLOW FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE- EMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS FIRST OF ALL HERE- AND
THEN ALSO IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHICH IS A ROOM DOWN ON THE
SECOND FLOOR. AB FIVE OF COURSE
WILL LET PEOPLE IN TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WILL BE ALSO
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO. WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. IF YOU LIKE
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT- YOU CAN
DO IT IN PERSON AND ONE OF
THESE TWO ROOMS. FORTY TWO OR
THREE OR- TWENTY TWENTY FORTY.
OR YOU CAN CALL AND WE HAVE A
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE THAT'S POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW SO
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE. FIVE TWO. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO ONE ONE TWO
FOUR ONE FOUR. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO ACCESS
YOUR HOBBY TELECONFERENCES DIM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR ARE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. SO WHEN WE MOVED TO
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AND IF YOU
ARE ON THE PHONES YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS THERE'S ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS COULD BE SURE
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBERS TO TRY TO
MEMBER LINE NUMBER. AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE A NEEDED AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. NOW PLEASE NOTE IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE. THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT AT FROM YOU. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
PATIENCE. A MINIMUM TEN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
IN PERSON I HAVE A CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE- TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER. AS WELL AS BEFORE
AS IS CUSTOMARY. HI THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. SO WE'VE GOT A TWELVE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA HI WITH
THREE BILLS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AND- WE'RE NOW HOPING
THAT OUR MEMBERS WILL COME. SO
WE CAN GET STARTED OUR ISERIES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA IS HERE
TO PRESENT HIS BILL- BUT WE'VE
GOT THE NUMBER THE PROBLEM AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS A NUMBER OF
NUMBERS OVER THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO SOMEONE COULD CALM
AND JUST GET AFTER AT LEAST LET
US- STARTED A MATCH. HAND BRAND
DOLLARS. PRESERVATIONISTS ON
THE WAY FROM THE AIRPORT SO.
RIGHT NOW PICKLING DOLLY YES
OKAY THANK YOU.
HIGHER UP FOR A
FREE PASS TO GO MY GOD LOOK AT
THIS THIS IS A GOLDMINE OKAY-
LET'S CALL THIS HEARING TO
ORDER. ITS OWN PLEASE ESTABLISH
A QUORUM ALLEN HERE ALLEN HERE
BATES. DALLI DALLI HERE
GONZALEZ. SKINNER STERN YOUR
STERN HEREBY CASKEY BY CASKEY
HERE YOU HAVE A GREAT. THE ROLE
WE WILL ABSOLUTELY YES HOW 2%
YEAH THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S. SO OKAY
SO LET'S START WITH YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. I'M TO
PRESENT ITEM TO THIS AB THREE
SIXTY THREE THE KARAKORAM WHERE
MEMORIAL AIR QUALITY SENSITIVE
PROGRAMS. HI YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. STATE
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND SPONSORS FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. I KNOW
SEVERAL DISCUSSIONS WERE HAD
AND WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB THREE
SIXTY THREE. WHICH SEEKS TO GET
MORE CLEAN VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
THROUGH THE ON ROAD HEAVY DUTY
VOUCHER INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
KNOWN AS THE V. I. P. TO. AB
THREE SIXTY THREE WOULD
AUTHORIZE CARB TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING UNDER V. I. P. TO. NO
MODEL YEAR RESTRICTIONS ON
SCRAPPAGE REQUIREMENT PROVIDED
TO THE MODEL YEARS AUTHORIZED
TO BE REGISTERED IN THE STATE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. ALL ON ROAD HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES REGARDLESS OF
VEHICLE TYPE. OR APPLICATION TO
PARTICIPATE IN V. I. P. TO.
EXISTING ENGINES TO BE REPLACED
WITH NEW ENGINES WITH LOWER
EMISSIONS. EXISTING VEHICLES
REGISTERED OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
TO PARTICIPATE AND V. I. P. TO
IF THEY OPERATE INTHE STATE AT
LEAST 75% OF THE TIME. NO FLEET
SIZE RESTRICTIONS BUT CARBS
AUTHORIZED TO LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF VOUCHERS PURFLEET. A YEAR
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG TERM
G. H. G. AND KNOX EMISSIONS
REDUCTION STRATEGY IT'S NEAR
TERM STRATEGY SHOULD INCLUDE
GETTING THE CLEANNESS HEAVY
DUTY COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGIES ON THE ROAD AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE SIXTY THREE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS NICOLE
RICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLE.
COALITION. OKAY MAY PROCEED.
MISTRY'S. YES HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR IMAGES WE CAN CLEAR PLEASE
PROCEED OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHO LAST. THE CALL
RIGHT PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLE
COALITION WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF AB THREE SIX THREE AND ARE
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THIS BILL IS ONE PIECE OF
A LARGER ON GOING CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE IMMEDIATE NEED FOR A
BEER TERM STRATEGY TO ACHIEVE
GREATER EMISSION REDUCTIONS
TODAY. THE BILL LAYS OUT A
FRAMEWORK THAT REMOVES THE
BARRIERS AND PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY. A NEW CAR MORE
YOUR V. I. P. PROGRAM TO
INCENTIVIZE THE BROADER
DEPLOYMENT OF LOW NOT HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS WHICH ARE NECESSARY
COMPONENTS OF ANY NEAR TERM
EMISSION REDUCTION STRATEGY.
THIS IS BECAUSE LOW NOT HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS ARE 90% CLEANER
THAN THEIR DIESEL COUNTERPARTS.
THEY ARE COST EFFECTIVE OPTION
IN COMPARISON. THEY ARE
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE TODAY
AND CAN BE CARBON NEGATIVE WITH
FUELED BY RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS.
AS WE GET COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
RIGHTLY POINTS OUT WE NEED TO
GET HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS
OFF THE ROAD TODAY IN ORDER TO
EXPERIENCE GREATER GHG AND
CRITERIA POLLUTANT REDUCTIONS
AND TO PROVE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS. FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND SPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE LIVING HERE GOOD
TO MOVEMENT CORRIDORS AND IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. THE
STATE HAS IDENTIFIED A LONGER
TERM SOLUTION AND IS WORKING
TOWARD THAT GOAL BUT WE NEED A
NEAR TERM PLAN AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO BE EXCLUSIVE AND NOT
APPROACH. THIS BILL REPRESENTS
THE ONLY REMAINING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM FOR LOW KNOCKS TRACKS
AND IT'S USING IT WITH THE
NECESSARY FLEXIBILITY WILL HELP
US TO ACHIEVE OUR PUBLIC POLICY
THE MISSION CALL EVEN SOONER. I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THE SUPPORT MANAGER
AND ASKED THE COMMITTEE FOR AND
I FELT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
STRESS. ALL RIGHT I'M SURE
THERE MAY BE ONE OTHER WHICH I
THINK THAT ENTRY INTO THIS YEAR
FROM THE WESTERN PROPANE GAS
ASSOCIATION. IS THAT RIGHT. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I'M
HERE IF YOU GUYS CAN HEAR ME
HAPPY TO PROVIDE REFER MARKS
YES PLEASE- THE WEST OF
PROPANE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR FUTURE. IN MEMBERS. ENTRY
ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
PROPANE GAS ASSOCIATION. DIESEL
TRUCKS ARE THE SINGLE LARGEST
SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
PURPOSE OF THE CAR MORE PROGRAM
IS ALWAYS BEEN TO REDUCE NEAR
TERM EMISSIONS. UNFORTUNATELY
RECENT DECISIONS HAVE RESULTED
IN THE NEED FOR THIS BILL.
CONTINUE TO. CARVE OUT A ROLE
IN THE OVERALL STRATEGY TO GET
YOUR LONG TERM GOALS GOALS OF
COMPETITORS. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT- THE PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS OF HAVING IMMEDIATELY
DEPLOYABLE TECHNOLOGY THAT
HELPS GET US THERE AS-
EMPHASIZED BY REGIONAL AIR
DISTRICTS- BOTH IN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF STATE AND OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE AS WELL. PROBABLY
INDICATE THAT THIS IS A PART OF
A STRATEGY THAT THE REGIONAL-
AIR REGULATORS ON THE GROUND
VERY MUCH WANT WITH RESPECT
YOU- TOOLS IN OUR TOOL KIT TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS. FROM MOBILE
SOURCES OF THE WESTERN
PROGRAMMING GAS ASSOCIATION AND
VOLUNTARY EVEN THOUGH ARE OUT
OF GAS WHICH IS THE PRODUCT
THAT PROPANE OFFERS. HE DOESN'T
HAVE A HUGE FOOTPRINT BUT
THEY'RE OUR FLEET OPERATORS
THAT DO USE- CONVERSION KITS TO
HAVE THEIR FLEET VEHICLES RUN
ON THIS CLEAN FUEL. WE ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
FACT THAT. VERY SOON- THE
PRODUCTION OF RENEWABLE PROPANE
WILL BECOME A REALITY. IN THE
UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AND RENEWABLE PROPANE HAS.
THE POTENTIAL TO HAVE A
NEGATIVE- CARMEN RATING- WHEN
YOU FACTOR IN HOW THE FUEL
SOURCES GENERATED. FOR THESE
REASONS WE THANK THE OPERA
BRING THE BILL FOR IT. AND THE
COMMITTEE. FOR GENERAL
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOU SOME. ALL RIGHT OUR NOT GO
TO PHONE LINES AND SEE I SEE
ANYONE HERE TO. AND OR IN
TWENTY FOUR. I WILL GO PHONE
LINES SEE IF THERE ANYONE WHO
WANTS. IN OF THE- ON THE PHONE.
SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE SIX
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME EIGHTEEN
ANTI OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU-
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE IN THE
PLACE BACKING Q. ONE MOMENT
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT.
AND OUR FIRST ONE WILL COME
FROM WIND THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THIRTY FIVE. I GUESS
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MICHAEL AFTER THE PRAYER AND MY
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL GO BACK TO THIRTY
FIVE NOW PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MR HERE- RYAN KENNY
WITH CLEAN ENERGY IN FRONT
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB THREE SIX THREE. SURE
NOBODY ELSE IS KILLING UP. OKAY
ALL RIGHT I AM LET'S GO I DON'T
I DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
LEADER OPPOSITION- AND- SO WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES I
DON'T SEE ON HERE PERSON ANYONE
THE PHONE LINES YOU WANT TO
VOICE CONCERNS OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. CHAU OPPOSITION FOR
AB THREE SIX THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR OKAY ALL RIGHT I'M-
I GUESS I CAN'T MOVE THE BILL-
BECAUSE I'M THE CHAIR SO ON THE
WE HAVE ACTUALLY. ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM SO- IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
UNTIL WE CAN SUPPORT THE BILL I
APPRECIATE YOUR- IT TAKES ME
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'RE AT A POINT NOW
IF. IF WE WANT TO CREATE THE
STATE GUIDELINES TO ALLOW FOR
MORE. TRUCKS TO GET- KARAM
WHERE MONEY IF THE AIR DISTRICT
ONE ADOPTEES. THESE GUIDELINES
THAT THAT CERTAINLY- IS GOOD
GOOD FOR ME SO- I KNOW YOU
GONNA TRANSPORTATION AFTER THIS
AS WELL SO IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
OTHERWISE I WILL SURELY BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND
RECOMMENDING THE MEMBER SUPPORT
IT TODAY. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR WORK MISTER CHAIR AND WHEN
THE TIME IS RIGHT I ASKED FOR.
THE COMMITTEES I BOOKED OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH ALL RIGHT. GREAT. ALL
RIGHT SO WE HAVE WENDY CARILLO
HERE YOU ARE HERE PRESENT ITEM
THREE THIS IS A BEFORE EIGHTY
ON HAZARDOUS MATERIALS. WE'LL
GET YOU MAY RECEIVE AN READY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS WHO-
WERE HERE EARLIER. TWO ZERO
ZERO ZERO TWO MILLION THREE
MILLION. DOLLARS THIS OKAY WELL
I AM A I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
THEM THE BILL FOR EIGHTY A
MEASURE THAT WILL STRAIN LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION AGAINST LOCAL THREATS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. INCLUDING
THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT A
FACILITY OR PORTION OF THE
FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS THAT
COST AND EXPOSURE. IN
CALIFORNIA MULTIPLE REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES HAVE JURISDICTION
OVER BUSINESSES THAT HANDLE OR
GENERATE HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
MATERIALS THAT POSE A RISK TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY.
LOCALLY A CERTIFIED UNIFIED
PROGRAM AGENCY OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS CUBA IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING AND ENFORCING
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS AND WASTE
LOSS AND THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER HAS GENERAL THIRTY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND
EXPANDED THE ALREADY. ONLY
AFTER A COUNTY WIDE EMERGENCY
IS DECLARED CURRENTLY SOME
FACILITIES THAT EMIT HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES CONTINUE TO OPERATE
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT MEET. THE
REGULATORY MINIMUM STANDARDS TO
CEASE OPERATIONS IMMEDIATELY A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF THIS TYPE OF
ATROCITY IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES- BEING THE EXIDE
BATTERY RECYCLING FACILITY AND
THE CITY OF VERNON WHICH
CONTINUOUSLY EXPOSE FAMILIES
AND RESIDENTS. OF MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AND OTHERSURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES TO DANGEROUS LEVELS
OF TOXIC LEAD FOR DECADES. THE
DELAY TO SHUT THIS FACILITY
DOWN LED TO EMISSIONS FROM THE
PLANT CONTAMINATING MORE THAN.
TEN THOUSAND. OF A RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES ACROSS NUMEROUS
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING EAST LOS
ANGELES BOYLE HEIGHTS AND
SOUTHEAST L. A. EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY WILL ENABLE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT
FACILITY OR A PORTION OF THE
FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE. THE OPERATIONS
THAT HAVE EXPOSED THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO HARMFUL TOXIC
MATERIALS UNTIL THAT ISSUE IS
CORRECTED. FOR THE PAST. GOSH
TWO THREE YEARS I HAVE. BEEN
WORKING TOGETHER TO BRING. GRAY
AUTHORITY TO LOCAL TOURIST. TO
TAKE THE APPROPRIATE ACTION
AGAINST THREATS TO OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
THAT I HAVE TAKEN THE
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
OPPOSITION WHO HAD NOW GONE
NEUTRAL. THE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
COMPOSED TO FOLLOW DEPARTMENT
THAT THE TO FOLLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS REGULATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO REPORTABLE AMOUNTS
UNTIL THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. ADOPTS IS REGULATION
ON THE SUBJECT I HAVE ALSO
ADDED LEGISLATIVE INTENT WITH
RESPECT TO DESCRIBING IMMINENT
AND SUBSTANTIAL. THREAT THAT IS
GIVEN THAT THERE IS NO- GIVEN
THAT THERE IS NO STATUTORY
DEFINITION OF THAT TERM. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME IN MY OFFICE ON THIS
URGENT ISSUE. AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS A STAKEHOLDERS TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD AND I
WANT TO SAY. WE HAVE DONE A LOT
TO DO THE- THE CLEAN UP
SURROUNDING EXCITE AND ENSURE
THAT EXCITE IS ACCOUNTABLE BUT
HOWEVER THEY FILED BANKRUPTCY
AND NOW THE STATE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS MAJOR
CLEANUP AND PERHAPS ONE OF THE
LARGEST. ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT THAT NEVER HAPPENS
EVER AGAIN ACROSS THE STATE TO
ANY COMMUNITY. IN CALIFORNIA.
ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IS
ROYCE LONG WHO IS THE COOPER
PROGRAM MANAGER OF THE- VALLEY
FIRE DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
CHIEF MARIO- DATAS OF THE L. A.
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT. DEGREE
WITNESSES. I'LL START WITH YOU-
MYSTERON. MODERATOR WE HAVE THE
WITNESSES TEAMED UP OR MAYBE
MERRY MAYBE I MISSED MR SET US.
YES IS MISTER SECURITY READY TO
START TO CHRISTMAS GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MORNING AGAIN MY NAME IS MINA
TRADE SHARES ON THE CHEAP OF
THE HEALTH HAZARDS WHICH YOU
KNOW THE VERSION OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT. SO WE
ARE THE CERTIFIED UNIFIED
PROGRAM AGENCY OR THE COOPER
AND MINISTER HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS UNIT BY PROGRAMS IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. I
SERVED AS A SUPERVISOR FOR
SEVEN YEARS ON THE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS SECTION AND
RESPONDED TO NUMEROUS HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS INCIDENTS INCLUDING
THE LEASE SO CANYON METHANE GAS
LEAK. IN JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN I ALSO RESPONDED TO THE
FRIEDMAN INCIDENT OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS MADE. WITH IT THANK
YOU CAN EXPLICITLY HIGHER. THIS
INCIDENT INVOLVED A METAL ROOF.
THAT A SECOND ON FROM BUSINESS
SITE. THE BUSINESS STRIPPING.
MY AND HAD LARGE. OF AND
HYDROCHLORIC ACID WITHOUT A PER.
ONE WEEK PRIOR TO THE FIRE
REACTION OCCURRED WITH
INCOMPATIBLE. AT THE FACILITY
WAS ISSUED A NOTICE OF
VIOLATION BUT THE AUTHORITY TO
CLOSE A PORTION OF THE FACILITY
WAS NOT AVAILABLE TO THE GROUP.
ALTHOUGH THE ARSON
INVESTIGATION WAS UNABLE TO
DETERMINE THE SOURCE OF THE
COMMISSION. IT IS SUSPECTED
THAT THE SECOND ILLEGAL
BUSINESS MAY HAVE CONTRIBUTED
OR BEEN THE CAUSE OF THE FIRE.
THIS INCIDENT RESULTED IN THE
EVACUATION OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE WITH TOXIC HEAVY METAL
CONTAMINATION FOUND THROUGHOUT
THE COMMUNITY. ULTIMATELY THIS
RESULTED IN UPWARDS OF A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR SUPERFUND
CLEANUP. PROVIDED BY UNITED
STATES ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY. AT THE AUTHORITY BEEN
AVAILABLE WHICH IS BEING SOUGHT
AFTER TODAY IT IS VERY POSSIBLE
THAT THIS ENTIRE INCIDENT COULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED. I'M HERE
TODAY TO URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
PASS A BEFORE EIGHTY. THE STORY
WILL ENHANCE THE COOPER'S
ABILITY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY FROM LEASES
OF HAZARDOUS MATERIALS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NUMBER IS SEVEN
THIS ROYCE LONG. AVAILABLE ON
THE PHONE LINE BECAUSE FOUR
NINE. YES I AM ABOUT ARE THERE
WE GO OKAY LET'S HEAR FROM MR
FROM RICE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING I MISTER GERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROYCE LONG ENOUGH TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM. ONE OF THE LARGEST
CITIES IN THE NATION.
TRANSALPINA BAHASA THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE FOR ABOARD.
ABOARD REPRESENT A HUNDRED FIVE
UNIFIED CARGO MAY JUST YOU
STATEWIDE ITS MISSION IS TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. IS REGULATE OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
BUSINESSES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THAT HANDLES AGAIN I HAS ITS
MATERIALS AND HAZARDOUS WASTE.
THESE BUSINESSES RANGING PARTS
ONE SMALL BUSINESSES SUCH AS
BORDER REPAIR AND DRY CLEANING.
TO LARGER BUSINESSES INVOLVED
WITH METAL PLATING CHEMICAL
FORMULATION AND REFINERIES.
CHARLIE QUEBEC LACKED THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO DIRECT
COMMITTED OR NOT COMMITTED
BUSINESS THE- JUSTICE
OPERATIONS IMMEDIATELY WENT UP
BY THE THREAT TO PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY. THIS LACK OF
AUTHORITY JEOPARDIZES OUR
ABILITY TO SWIFTLY TAKE ACTION
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY. THIS
APPLY TO THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU
FOR SERVICE PROVIDER WHETHER
MAY WOULD MAKE IT EASIER HI
SPEED TOXIC HEAVY METAL. ALL OF
THE J. SEND BY MAIL DR
COMMUNITY. THIS WAS COMPLETELY
PREVENTABLE AND TWO OTHER
INCIDENTS IN COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE TAKE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY WHEN THEY HAVE A SILLY
REGENERATING. YOUR GAS THAT ARE
RELEASED FROM A ROYAL CAL. POLY
AS A RESULT OF A TRUCK BY
REACTING WITH THE WATER IN THE
AREA TO BE JUST A HOPE YOU'RE A
CATHOLIC CLOUT. I WOULD TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE SOUGHT MEDICAL
ATTENTION PROMISE REALLY. AFTER
THIS RELEASE BECAUSE THERE WAS
SOME SMALLER RELEASES FROM THE
SITE THE FACILITY THE IMPACT OF
THE COMMUNITY. I RACES EXAMPLE
BECAUSE DURING IN THE VAN
CONTRA COSTA- BUT LACK THE
ABILITY TO REQUIRE DISABILITY
TO STOP OPERATIONS. TELL US
THAT THE EVALUATION COULD BE
PERFORMED. EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
BUT PROVIDED ALREADY. INDUSTRY
HAS RAISED CONCERNS REGARDING
THEPOTENTIAL PARKER PRECIOUS
THAN AVERAGE. USE OF THIS PARTY.
BASICALLY WITH THE- USE OF THE
IN AFTER. AT THE REQUEST OF
INDUSTRY THE COUPLE BOARD MADE
FOLLOWING AMEND. TO LIMIT
AUTHORITY WHERE ISN'T A AT AN
SUCH DANGER. THAT ARE IN THE
ALL THE STANDS ONE DANGER.
NUMBER TWO SOCIAL THE BECOME
WITH PROVIDE. I'M LOOKING THE
LENS SORRY YOU COULD JUST WRAP
YOUR COMMON. YES AND THEN- THE-
AND TO WORK INDUSTRY IN THAT IT
WE HAVE ANY FUTURE CAN SIGN
CENTER AND- SIMPLE A PARTY. IS
A FACTOR WITHIN NEW. TALKING AB
ANYONE LOCAL AUTHORITIES AT THE
ME TO ACT YOU NEED JUST ABOUT
CONSTITUENT. WHEN SUCH AS PER
HELPING YOU. SO YOUR OPERATE
FOUR EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK
FOR YOUR SO MUCH. OKAY LET'S GO.
THE I DON'T SEE ANYONE HE- HE
OR AND A TWENTY FORTY ONE TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON AS ANYONE IN
THE PHONE LAW. MODERATOR ANY
THE PHONE LINES WHO WOULD LIKE.
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB FOUR
EIGHTY. PLEASE AND GENTLEMEN
THE FARM TO SHOW. S. FINANCE.
OF FOUR EIGHTY PER PRESS
FOLLOWED BY ZERO THIS TIME. AND
WE WILL BEGIN TODAY WINDS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CALMLY WITH
THE L. A. BOARD OF DEEPER
SPROUT. A CUT BY OF THE BILL
MARKETING DIAZ. ADULT INDUSTRY
I'M FOR THE WORK ON THE FIELD.
AND AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI FOR EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE.
THIRTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN JUSTIN MILNE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION AND
MORE BERMAN HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS- WE ALSO CO
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE AND-
THANK YOU FOR SHARING IT WE
URGE YOU AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE WON WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. LINE SIXTY TWO YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
MODELING COOPER FROM NELSON
MARC MAURER ON BEHALF OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. OKAY ARM LETS ME OUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE ANYONE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WE
LEAD OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE.
ANSWERING PERSON ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR WHO LIKE
TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT AB
FORTY OR ORG SPEAKING
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. TO
SPEAK IN A POSITION AB FOR
EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR OKAY.
WHAT ARE THE ITEM NOW COMES
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IF MY NEW
VICE CHAIR DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR THOUGHTS. BUT THIS
BILL. I KNOW JUST APPRECIATE
THAT A NUMBER OF- AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN THAT REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION I'M NOT SURE THEY
JUMPED ON AND SUPPORT. BUT
THERE ARE I BELIEVE THEY'VE
GONE NEUTRAL IS THAT CORRECT
ASSEMBLY RECORDS YEAH SO. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. PRIME I'M
TRIMMING IS FOR THE BILL- AND
SEE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO I
YOU KNOW I. DOBBS I CONTINUE TO
BE SO OUTRAGED BY THIS THE FACT
THAT THE BEHAVIOR OF- AND SOME
OF THE FOLKS OF THESE COMPANIES
HAVE LED TO SUCH ENVIRONMENTAL
AND HEALTH DAMAGE PUBLIC HEALTH
DAMAGE AND- YOUR DISTRICT AND
ELSEWHERE AND SO I CERTAINLY.
AM VERY HOPEFUL THAT THIS BILL
WILL TAKE A SIGNIFICANTLY
PRESENTED AT THIS ONE NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN- SO. WITH THAT I
WILL CERTAINLY AND- BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU. IT IS A MOVING
THE BILL OR OR- NO OKAY TO GET
A SUPPOT IT OKAY OKAY ALL
RIGHT. SO WILL WILL. NOT A
WHOLE HERE CLOSE AND WILL
ACCEPT THE- MOTION WHEN SOMEONE
ELSE GETS IT. THANK YOU I CAN
DO IT OKAY OKAY SIR TO SEE
YOUNG YEAH OKAY. AND WITH THE
BILL. SO WE'VE GOT TO LEAVE
THAT ON THE RECORD. THEY DO
LIKE TO CLOSE HONORED SENATOR I
PRE AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WANT TO GIVE A PERSONAL SHOUT
OUT TO ALL OF OUR LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING VISION CITY TERRACE
IT HAS BEEN. SUCH A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON IT FOR A FEW
YEARS WE WANTED TO GET IT RIGHT
I JUST THINK IT'S OUTRAGEOUS
THAT. EXCITE AS THE COMPANY HAS
COST TAXPAYER DOLLARS MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND HAS
FILED BANKRUPTCY LEAVING THOSE
COST NOW TO THE STATE A USC
STUDY RECENTLY I BELIEVE IT WAS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN- THE STUDY
WITH IN PARTNERSHIP WITH L. A.
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
SUGGESTED AND ACTUALLY STATED
THAT CHILDREN IN MY COMMUNITY
AND SURROUNDING AREAS WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR BABY TEETH. THOSE
BABY TEETH CONTAIN LEAD THERE
IS NO AMOUNT OF LEAD IN THE
HUMAN BODY THAT IS SAFE AT ALL.
SO THE FACT THAT. THIS THIS IS
THE REALITY FOR MY COMMUNITY
AND THE HEALTH DISPARITIES THAT
LOW INCOME CAN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THAT HAS BEEN AND THAT
HAVE BEEN DISADVANTAGED FOR SO
LONG. THIS IS OUR REALITY THIS
IS MY DISTRICT AND I JUST I
FIND IT COMPLETELY APPALLING
THAT WE HAVE TO FORCE.
COMPANIES TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT
AND WHAT IS JUST WHEN IT COMES
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT NO OTHER
EXCITED- TYPE EVENT CAN EVER
OCCUR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GIVING. OUT LOCAL
AUTHORITY TO ENSURE THAT THIS
IS THE CORRECT STEP MOVING
FORWARD IT IS COMMON SENSE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT WILL
ENABLE LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO ACT
IN THE INTERESTS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE PUBLIC'S
HEALTH. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT TO THE BILL'S REMOVE.
I SAID CONSUMPTIONS COLORADO.
ALLEN HI WHEN I BATES AYE IT'S
AYE DALY GONZALEZ SKINNER STERN
BY CASKEY. CURRENTLY YOU ARE
WELL ON YOUR WAY OUT OF THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR MISTER
SUPPORTING IN THAT PROCEDURE
WORK ON THIS THING BUT THERE'S
A LOT MORE TO DO. THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S NOW GO TO
ROBERT RIVAS WHO'S HERE- I'M
SORRY JIM. HE'S I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN HERE LONGER ALL  HT
RIGHT WELL THAT OKAY LET'S SEE
THAT'S THE KIND OF.
GRACIOUSNESS THAT TIME SUMMARY
OKAY SO WHAT IT WHAT WE WILL GO
TO YOU TENS AND EVEN WHEN SUCH
A LONG TIME- ITEM FIVE A. B.
SEVEN FIFTY THREE. BROWNFIELD'S
REMEDIATION AND REDEVELOPMENT.
THANK OU SO VERY MUCH THANK
YOU TO MY- DEAR COLLEAGUES. AS
WELL. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBER I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE WHICH
EXTENDS THE SUNSET OF THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP FUN AND CREATES A TASK
FORCE THAT WILL STUDY.
EXPANDING ELIGIBLE USES OF THE
FUND TO INCLUDE BROWNFIELD
REMEDIATION FOR HOUSING THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP FUND WAS CREATED OVER
THIRTY YEARS AGO. AND HAS BEEN
EXTENDED NUMEROUS TIMES SINCE
ITS CREATION IT HAS BECOME ONE
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
WATER SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA.
THANKS TO THE EFFORTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO REDUCE SUCH FUEL
LEAKS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION THERE ARE FAR
FEWER NEW APPLICANTS TO THE
FUND THAN EVER BEFORE. WHICH
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROTECT PRIORITIZE FUNDING TO
CLEAN UP PROPERTIES ON WHICH
HOUSING CAN BE BUILT AB SEVEN
FIFTY THREE DOES NOT CREATE A
NEW TAXES MORE FEET. IT MERELY
EXTENDS THE SUNSET OF THIS
INCREDIBLE RESOURCE AND
EXPLORES A PATHWAY TOWARD
REMEDIATING BROWNFIELD SITES IN
JOB IN TRANSIT RICH AREAS
CALIFORNIA HAS A MASSIVE
HOUSING STORAGE OF SQUARE
FOOTAGE. HOUSING. AND NEAR
TRANSIT HOWEVER BILLABLE URBAN
INFILL LAND IS OFTEN PASSED
OVER DUE TO ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION FROM PREVIOUS
DEVELOPMENT. THESE CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES TAKE UP VALUABLE
LAND IN AREAS WHERE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS NEEDED THE MOST
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE WILL
SUPPORT THE STATE'S GOALS IN
REDUCING CARBON EMISSIONS AND
URBAN HOUSING. AND BUILDING
URBAN HOUSING SO. I'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
OPPOSITION CONCERNS LEAVING
THIS BILL WITH NO OPPOSITION MY
WITNESSES ARE BROWN FEEL
PRACTITIONER MARCUS NEED ME
BANK AND IGNAT- NOT SHE'LL DIE
READ FROM CENTER FOR CREATIVE
LAND RECYCLING. OKAY LET'S GO
WITH YOUR FIRST LEAD WITNESS.
MARCUS THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL MY NAME
IS MARKETING THE BANK I'VE BEEN
AN ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTANT
BROWNFIELD ACT INSURING
CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY. UNDERGROUND STORAGE
TANK CLEANUP FUNDS FACILITATED
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION AND
PROTECTION OF HUMAN HEALTH
EARLY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA SENSE AN EVALUATION
PROGRAM EXPANSION TO SERVE A
BROADER UNIVERSE NONCONTROLLING
BROWNFIELD SITES. AS WELL TIME.
I NEED A HOUSING TO AND CAL
COULD. AND THE NEED FOR
WORKFORCE HOUSING AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT URBAN COMMUNITIES
PERHAPS GREATER TODAY WILL BE
FOR. MANY POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITY
PROPERTIES URBAN AREAS YOU'RE
WELCOME. WHEN THE BECAUSE OF
THE HISTORIC USE IS PERCEIVED
SECOND PART OF THE LAST TRIBUTE
MAKE REDEVELOPMENT FOR HOUSING
IMPOSSIBLE. IN REALITY MANY OF
THE SITE THE BEST MANAGEABLE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLICATIONS AND
BAKURA RESOURCE TO ASSESS YOU
MEDIATE OR PASSED OVER HER
DEVELOPMENT AND REMAINED
ABANDONED FOR DECADES. AN
EXAMINATION OF THE CLEAN UP ON
THE BILITY TO BE APPLIED TO THE
REHABILITATION OF THESE HOUSING
APPROPRIATE SITES ON THE
POSSIBLE APPLICATIONS OTHER
ENVIRONMENTALLY DAMAGED LAND.
FOR OTHER OBJECTION OBJECTIVES
IS WELL TIMED AND CRITICALLY
NEEDED THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
TO- A NICE DAVID DIED IT TIRE
IT. YES NINETY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS MY
NAME IS EXACERBATED AND IM THE
DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS FOR THE
CENTER FOR CREATIVE NINE
RECYCLING OR SEEK HERE FOR THE
LAST TWENTY TWO YEARS HAS BEEN
THE ONLY NATIONAL NONPROFIT
DEDICATED TO SUSTAINABLE RE USE
OF UNDER UTILIZED PROPERTIES.
BEFORE SEE CLEAR I WAS TO BE
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT MANAGER FOR
THE CITY OF EMERYVILLE WHERE I.
BRITAIN SUSTAINABLE URBAN
INFILL PROJECTS FOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS AND COLLABORATED WITH
OTHERS NATIONALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY. NOW MORE THAN
EVER FUNDING FOR DUE DILIGENCE
AND CLEAN UP IT'S ESSENTIAL FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE MITIGATION AND
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT AND
HOUSING IS THE LOSS OF
REDEVELOPMENT FIFTY SEVEN Q.
RELIABLE LOCALLY SOURCED FUNDS
CRESSMAN AND CLEAN UP THE
RECENT IMPROVEMENTS THE TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING DO NOT
OFFSET THIS LOSS THE STATE
SIMPLY DOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDS TO ACCESS AND CLEAN UP.
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF SITE
THAT WILL BE. NEEDED PARK
INFILL HOUSING. THE NEW MODEST
BECAUSE- ESTIMATE TEN OF
MILLIONS OF AND WILL ARE NEEDED
TO KEEP UP WITH THE STATE INTO
HOUSE THAT ME THAT IS MY THAT
ACROSS IN DEVELOPERS INTO NOT
HAVE. LIKE SOME VERY
COMPETITIVE GRANT AVAILABLE
FROM THE S. AND KELLY P. A.
THERE ARE FEW RESOURCES
INITIATE AND PURSUE DEVELOPMENT
OF VACANT UNDER UTILIZED FOR
BLIGHTED INFILL PROPERTIES. AB
SEVENTY THREE PROVIDES FUNDS
THE STATE NEEDED ME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ARM WILL GO
NEXT TO FOLKS WHO WANT TO WEIGH
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FIFTY
THREE I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE
IN PERSON OR IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- BUT IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE TO LIKE TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL-
MODERATOR PLEASE. ENACTUS TO
THEM. THANK YOU OUR LADY JOHN
ON THE PHONE LINES TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN FIFTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE FILED
BY ZERO FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVEN FIFTY THREE AND WE WERE
LINE THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS OF THE MATTER NOT
LIKE HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY GREATER SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE PARK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
YOUR PERSONAL SUPPORT FOR A BI.
SEVEN FIFTY THREE. NOBODY ELSE
IS QUEUING UP MR CARE ALL
RIGHT. LET'S BRING YOU BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
CALL- I'M SORRY. OPPOSITION
AND- I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE
ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYONE ON IN PERSON I DON'T IN
PESON WHEN THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR LIKE TO VOICE ANY
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO RITUALS
OPPOSITION FOR AB. SEVEN FIFTY
THREE. NOBODY IS GIVING UP THE
STRUCTURE OKAY- LET'S BE BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS
THOUGHTS QUESTIONS- I THINK
IT'S MISTER CHAIR FOR IT
SUPPORT EXTENSION OF THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP PROGRAM FOR TEN YEARS
AS OUTLINED IN THE STAFF REPORT
NOW MOVED BILLS. OKAY IN
ADDITIONAL PARTS THE BOOK THE
BILL'S REMOVED AS YOU LIKE IT
CLOSE HOWEVER. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION RIGHT ALL RIGHT
THE BILL TO MOVE I SENATE WITH
CASKEY CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
SEVEN FIVE THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN HI ALAN I
BATES ABSTAINED. IT'S STAINED
DALLY GONZALEZ SKINNER STERN
BURKE OWSKI BY. AYE CASKEY AYE.
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
FOLKS TO ADD ONS BUT
TEMPERATURE. YOUR EFFORTS. OKAY
I'M NOW WE'RE GOING TO
RODRIGUEZ WHO IS NUMBER ONE IN
OUR AGENDA WITH. AB. TWO EIGHTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
IN THE MORNING COLLEAGUES-
THIRTY THIS MORNING AND- I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT- AND WORK
ON THIS BILL AND THE LIKES NOW
THEY'LL BE SENT TO THE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS- THAT
WERE PROPOSED I AND YOU KNOW
I'M HERE THIS MORNING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO EIGHT FOUR- WHICH-
SEEKS TO DIRECTED THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO SET AN OVERALL CLIMATE GOAL.
FAR STATES NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS AS PART OF NEXT YEAR'S
SCOPING PLAN PROCESS NOW EVEN
IF CARBON EMISSIONS STOPPED
RIGHT NOW. WE ALREADY HAVE MORE
CARBON IN OUR ATMOSPHERE THAN
SCIENTISTS AND CLIMATE EXPERTS
SAY SAFE. AND AS WE ALL KNOW
WE'RE NOT GOING TO STOP THE
MADE IN- E. MEETING- IN CARBON-
AT THIS. VERY MOMENT. IT'S A
SEQUESTRATION OF CARBON IN
SOILS FORESTS WETLANDS AND-
OTHER NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS- IS CURRENTLY THE ONLY
PROVEN WAY TO REMOVE CARBON
FROM OUR ATMOSPHERE AT A LARGE
SCALE. OR A POTENTIALLY LARGE
SCALE. AND SO IN FACT IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT SEQUESTRATION
ALONE COULD BRING US NEARLY 20%
OF THE WAY TO MEET OUR STATE
CLIMATE GOALS. AND TO CLARIFY
THE A. R. B.'S SCOPING PLAN IS
NON BINDING. IT'S NOT
REGULATORY IT'S NOT- REGULATORY
NATURE AND IT SIMPLY IS A
PLANNING EXERCISE THAT IS
DESIGNED TO SET GOALS AND
PROVIDE POLICY OPTIONS. FOR THE
FUTURE YOU KNOW THE SCOPING
PLAN ALREADY DEALS WITH ALMOST
EVERY SECTOR OF OUR STATE
ECONOMY. AND IT MAKES NO SENSE
TO LEAVE THIS IMPORTANT CLIMATE
SOLUTION ON THE TABLE. N. F. T.
O. AND WE HAVE AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. IN THIS EFFORT TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS AND TO FIND A
REASONABLE PATH. FORWARD THAT
EVERYONE CAN GET ON BOARD WITH
YEAH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISTER SHARE. WITH ME
HERE TO- I HAVE- TO TESTIMONIES
MACHEL THE CERRO OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND BRIAN- SHAUB OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGICULTURAL NETWORK. THANK
MADE UP YOUR I'M GOOD MORNING
OUT OF THE SOUTH AFTER- WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY I
DIRECTOR OF PROGRAM ONLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY IT
ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE ON THE
TEMPERTON THANK. THANK OUR YOU
NEED. NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED ARE IN YOUR AND LAN
REPUBLICAN AND THE HEALTH OF
OUR- NO HELP ADVANCE. I'M AS
WELL AS OTHER BENEFIT. A NUMBER
OF SCIENTIFIC ANNOUNCED THAT
YOU HAVE ALL WE ASK OUR- FOR
ACTION LIKE URBAN FOREST.
RESTORATION FIRE RIGHT
REDUCTION PLAN ACTIVATION.
RIDING AND LAND MANAGEMENT. ALL
THANK YOU CAN I CAN TRY. HI
MICHAEL. I NEED YOUR I'M A THE
PROJECT WE NEED AT LIKE HIGHER
CHANCE NOT ALL RIGHT. ONE AT
DECADE THERE'S BEEN TO GET MORE.
OPIC THAT'S ALL I'M NOT AWARE
AND I AM NOT THE ACCOUNTING
THAT AND IDENTIFYING BAD THAT
ON OCTOBER I MEAN ACTION IN THE
BACK YARD I HAVE ALL THE WORK
YOUR CALL INC WHERE. ACTION
THAT. ANOTHER FACTOR. THANK NOW
AND THEN PARKING. PROVIDING
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS YEAH THAT
CALIFORNIA'S NOT PLAN AREN'T
BEING IT CLASSICAL. THE AGENCY
COURT WITH CLEARLY. COOPER YOU.
RIGHT CLICK REQUIREMENTS ALL
YEAH STRATEGY AND NOT NOT NOT I
THANK GOD YOU ARE AMONG THEM
AND NEED AN ACCOUNT OTHER
IMPORTANT AT. I DON'T WORK IN A
BANK FOR NEARLY TWENTY YEARS IN
PROGRESS. WHAT HAPPENED BUT
ALSO WHERE PROGRESS I'M NOT.
DAHLE WONDERED. IN DAHLE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT I GUESS
NOW WE'RE GOING TO SHOW HE'S
RIGHT- FROM TOUGHER CLIMATE ARE
CLOSE BURKE. YES THANK YOU. HMM
FINDING FRENCH AND I IN THE
OKAY DIRECTOR FOR THE COW
BECAUSE NOT NETWORK OR CAN'T.
WE ARE A- OF FARMERS THE- AND
THE PANEL I. WORKING TO.
AGRICULTURE SOLUTION CLIMATE.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TWO
EIGHTY CORPORATE RECOGNIZE THE
NEW FOR. TO BAN THE CLIMATE
GOAL AND RELATED STRATEGIES FOR
ASKING PORTENT NATURAL WORKING
LANDS. WE AGREE WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR THAT WE MUST FIND
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS THAT IMPROVE
THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY. AND
RESILIENCE OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS. AB THIRTY FOUR
EMBRACES THE MULTIPLE BENEFITS
AND DEVELOP THE NECESSARY BIG
PICTURE ROAD MAP. WE
DESPERATELY NEED TO BRING
WORKING LAND SOLUTION TO SCALE
IN WAYS THAT WORK WITH AND FOR
FARMERS. DURING THE PANDEMIC
LAST YEAR WE HAD MORE FARMERS
THAN EVER BEFORE SIGNING UP FOR
THE CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURAL
PROGRAMS LIKE THE ALTERNATIVE
MANURE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. AND
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM. EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY FOUR WILL ALLOW THE
STATE TO BETTE UNDERSTAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES THE SCALE OF THIS
WORK IN MEANINGFUL WAYS. END OF
SUPPORT FARMERS WHO ARE
DEMONSTRATING TODAY EVEN DURING
UNCERTAIN TIMES BUT THEY WANT
THE STATE'S CLIMATE EFFORT TO
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT R. LET'S SEE THIS
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON EITHER HERE OR IN TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NINE LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR PEOPLE WHO
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO EIGHTY FOUR. TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR AB TWO EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WELL WILL BEGIN TODAY
WITH WIND SEVENTEEN. RICHARD
MEMBERS ALEX OR THE STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FOREST FOUNDATION AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
WANT TO COMMENT ON THE WITHOUT
AMONG CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
FIND TWENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
TWENTY MINUTES CHAIR MEMBERS
JUST IN ROWS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM AND PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AMERILA CALIFORNIA LEAVE
CONSERVATION VOTERS IMPORT.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR MARK
SPENCER MAKER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE COST CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS. REYES TRUSTED
MECHANIC WHERE VALLEY OPEN
SPACE AND FORTY ALL IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO EIGHTY FOUR. NINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS CAN GO ON BEHALF OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY TWO YOU
ARE OPEN. BILL MURPHY HER
ELDERS CLIENT ACTIONS NOR CAL
AND SOCAL CHAPTERS AND ALSO
THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY IN
SUPPORT. WINE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ALEXIS CHAVEZ OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE FORTY YOU
ARE UP. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS DIRECT MARKETS ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST AND THE CARBON CYCLE
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. NINE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS BREANNA ON
BEHALF OF MENTAL MENTAL
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION AIR LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
SUPPORT. ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
NUMBER OF NIKITA KARATE WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY NINE YOUR OPEN.
MORNING MR JANET JOHNSON LINE
HIM UP WITH A CALIFORNIA
COMPOSE COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KAREN NUMBER CANNELLA
EVENT THREE HUNDRED THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION CALLING FOR
GREATER SUPPORT FOR A BI TO
EIGHTY FOUR. BERNIE I DIGITAL
PARTICIPANTS WISHING TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI TO EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY. LATE EIGHTY S. THANK
YOU WENT OUT OF Q. IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN
WE'LL GET YOU BACK ON IN THE
MEANTIME WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY TWO. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS LIVES FOR THE LOTTO WITH
ECONOMIC COUNTY LOCAL TASK
FORCE WASTE DIVERSION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. WHITE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHTEEN A GALLIARD FOR
THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN. FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS A COUPLE OF
GOULD THE PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FIND SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. MOVING ALONG THE
LINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
THIS CONSTRUCTION WITH THE
CENTER FOR OCEANIC AWARENESS
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. SURE THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. LET'S GO
TO OPPOSITION AND WE I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TO FOLKS
WHO REALLY TO TESTIFIED LIED
OPPOSITION WE'VE GOT TAYLOR
RUSSIAN WHOSE POLICY ADVOCATE
FOR COMPANY FARM BUREAU AND
THEN LAST SUMMER THORN- FROM
THE CALCHAMBER. MR WITH YOU AND
TAYLOR. GOOD MORNING MR CHEN
MEMBERS TAYLOR RUSSIAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE LEAH AND A
COALITION OF AG AND BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE TWENTY FOUR UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED I LIKE GOING TO BE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THE ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND MYSTERY THIS
HAPPENS ALONG WITH HIS STAFF-
WILLINGNESS TO DISCUSS OUR
CONCERNS. THE MEN TO REFLECT
PROGRESS BUT WE STILL FEEL
THEIR SEVERAL PROVISIONS THAT
ARE MISSING FROM THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY IN DIRECTING AND
FRAMING CARBS GOAL SETTING
ACTION FIRST AS WE MENTIONED IN
THE CASE FOR ALL OF THE
COMPONENTS OF THE SCOPING PLAN
AND NATURAL WORKING LANDS
CLIMATE SMART- GOAL SHOULD
REALLY BE CRAFTED BASED ON
WHAT'S ECONOMICALLY AND
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE
ESPECIALLY FOR THE WORKING LAND
SECTOR WHAT AGRA NAMIK LEE
FEASIBLE WILL BE REALLY
IMPORTANT CONSIDERING. THE
DRAMATIC CHANGES WE'LL SEE IN
LAND USE PATTERNS AND CROP
DIVERSITY AND CERTAINLY WATER
SCARCITY WITHOUT THAT CRITERIA
BE INCLUDED ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL FAILS TO DIRECT CARPETS IN
A CLINICAL PREDICATED ON WHAT
CAN BE ACHIEVED THROUGH
VOLUNTARY ACTION BY PRIVATE AND
NATIONAL WORKING LANDHOLDERS
NOT ONLY ARE THEY PREDOMINATELY
NOT COVERED ENTITIES UNDER CAP
AND TRADE BUT THIS COMMITMENT
TO SORT OF HARNESS THE DEPRIVE
INVESTMENT WILLINGLY- IS
CONSISTENT WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL ACTIONS. THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER CARBS AND
SORORITY AND WE HOPE THIS
LEGISLATORS INTENT AND I'D ALSO
LIKE TO ADD THE FARM SECTOR IS
IN THE PROCESS OF MAKING SOME
PRETTY DAFT TOUGH DECISIONS FOR
SHIPPING OUT OF COALBED TIPPING
INTO A DROUGHT WITH LABOR
SHORTAGES AND- UNFORTUNATELY
WILDFIRE CHALLENGES IN SUMMER
ASKING THE MOST BASIC QUESTIONS
LIKE DO I GROW ANYTHING. AND
THAT THE SPONSOR NOTED STILL
ARE FROM COMMUNITIES WANT TO
STEP UP AND CONTRIBUTE TO
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND SO. IN
ORDER TO DO THAT WE KNOW THAT
IF WE PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
TOOLS THEY'LL GET THEIR AND THE
CLIMATE STUDIES SHOW CALIFORNIA
NEEDS INTO BUT ENABLING
PERMANENT CHANGE INCLUDING THAT
CULTURAL CHANGE REALLY REQUIRES
AN UNDERSTANDING AND RESPECT
FOR THE SACRIFICE THAT IT TAKES
TO MPLEMENT THE PRACTICES AND
THE TRADE OFFS THAT ARE
ENCOURAGED TO BE EXPLICIT. THAT
THIS CLIMATE GOAL IS ROOTED. IN
A VOLUNTARY HANDING GLOVE ACT.
IS REALLY AND- AS WE RESPECT
REQUEST THE COMMITTEE CAN. THE
THAT NOW LOOKING FOR. THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW I. WE'VE GOT AND WE
ARE HERE IN PERSON ON MEMBERS
NICE AS THE OTHER FOR THE FIRST
FIFTY MONTHS WE ARE THERE THE
HELP. CURVE WE DO RESPECTFULLY
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL THIS WOULD
BE OF COURSE THE FIRST TIME
CARBON NEUTRALITY IS CODIFIED
AND WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE GET ALL
THAT RIGHT. SO FIRST ASSURING
THAT REUSING HARMONY TRAVEL THE
IN A CONSISTENT WAY ACROSS
REGULATIONS AND STATUTES AND
SECOND THAT THE CARBON
NEUTRALITY REQUIREMENTS DON'T
FALL ON ANY ONE PARTICULAR
SECTOR AND CENTER FLIGHT ON THE
KANEMI WIDE BASIS. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS TO MORE
ACTIVELY INCLUDE THE AXE
SPECIFIC SECTORS IN THE BILL
AND THAT'S VERY HELPFUL INSTEAD
OF DELEGATING THE PROCESS
ENTIRELY TO THE AIRPORT- EVER
WITH THE BILL STILL CAN BE
INTERPRETED AS REQUIRING A
CARBON EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOAL
ON THE AGRICULTURAL SECTOR
SPECIFICALLY. SO REGIONAL LINES
CAN DISAGREE ABOUT THE
pSO WE DO CONTINUE AS MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE FARM BUREAU
INDICATED TO REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR INCLUDE A SPECIFIC
RESIDENT REFERENCE IN THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE BILL. TO THE
NON BINDING VOLUNTARY NATURE OF
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND GOALS
ON THE ACCEPTOR WHILE THE AIR
B. IS CONTINUING THE SCOPING
PLAN PROCESS WHICH IS SET TO
COMPLETE AT THE END OF NEXT
YEAR. SO WE UNTIL THEN WE DO
RESPECTFULLY REMAIN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS. AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITH. SO
LET'S NOW GO TO- THE PHONE
LINES THEY DON'T UNISON IN
PERSON WITH THE PHONE LINES. TO
TAKE ANY TESTIMONY TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB TWO EIGHTY FOR ANYTHING ON
THE LINE'S MODERATOR.
ARTICULATE THIS SHOW-
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE.
SEVENTY NINE. SEVENTY NINE YOU
ARE OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE ON MUTE. AND
THEY'RE NOT RESPONDING- FOR
ANYBODY ELSE TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR A. TWO FOR TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. NOBODY
ELSE IS QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR
OKAY. I'M THANK YOU SORTS
BRINGS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS THOUGHTS
CONCERNS. SENATOR WITH CASKEY.
WELL FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR- HI ACCEPTING
THE MEMON SAID THAT THE STAFF
IS WORKED OUT I AS YOU KNOW
I'VE HAD PROBLEMS WITH THE
BILL- IN THE PAST I'VE HAD
PROBLEMS WITH THE AIR BOARD ON
FIGHTING WITH THEM ON THE
SCOPING PLAN AND WHAT WE KNOW
IT'S NOT. BINDING IT THAT
CERTAINLY HAS AN IMPACT OF POOR
POLICIES GOING TO GO AND I WAS
FOUND TROUBLING WHEN WE HAVE
NATURAL WORKING LANDS YOU KNOW
THE SENATE THREE YEARS AGO
STARTED IN THE CAP AND TRADE
BUDGET HAD NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR NATURAL WORKING
LANDS THE- SPEAKER AND THE
GOVERNOR TOOK THAT OUT AND- BUT
WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
ALTERNATIVE. MANURE MNAGEMENT
AND I'LL BE LEAVING HERE TO GO
VOTE ON THE BUDGET THAT HAS A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION FOR
ALTERNATIVES TO BURNING
AGRICULTURAL WASTE BUT THOSE
ARE REALLY RUN BY THE RESOURCE
AGENCY OR THE AGRICULTURAL
AGENCY SO I WANTED TO HEAR FROM
YOU. YOU'VE ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS
BECAUSE YOU MADE THE AIRPORT
THE LEAD ON THE TERMS TURNING
THE PRACTICES THE POLICIES THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES WHAT WILL
HAPPEN I MEAN. WE SAID YOU KNOW
WE WILL CERTAINLY USE SOME CAP
AND TRADE MINOR TRY TO USE SOME
CAPTURE MONEY TO DO THE THINGS
THAT WE THINK ARE INCENTIVIZE
THAT OF THAT- NOW WERE YOU
GOING TO INTEGRATE TO
RECOMMENDATION SO. EXPLAIN HOW
YOU SEE THE VALUE OF THE
RESOURCE AGENCY AND THE
AGRICULTURAL AGENCIES
COORDINATING WITH THE AIRPORT-
FOR THESE ALL THESE BENEFITS
THAT WE WANT LET'S JUST
STIPULATE TO THAT WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN THIS
SPACE- SO SENATORS WE'VE
DISCUSSED AND I THINK YOUR-
COMMENT IS A VERY GOOD ONE-
WHERE THE INTENT OF. OF THIS
LEGISLATION THIS EFFORT IN
PARTICULAR IS TO BRING THESE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES TOGETHER
THESE YOU KNOW THESE
STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE CERTAINLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY.
OF THE SCOPING PLAN AND THERE
HAS BEEN. SOME PIECES OF
NETWORKING LAN SCATTER ACROSS
THE COPING PLANS OF THE IDEAS
TO CERTAINLY. YOU KNOW HAVE A
YOU KNOW STRONG A LEVEL OF THE
SOME COORDINATION ACROSS THESE
AGENCIES. TO HOPEFULLY DO A
DEEPER DIVE INTO THIS ISSUE OF
NATIONAL WORKING LANDS TO SEE
HOW IT IS THAT WE CAN LEVERAGES
NATIONAL WORKING LANDS TO YOU
KNOW SENATE PLAY A MORE
PROMINENT ROLE IN MEETING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. OR YOU KNOW
ACHIEVING A LOT OF TIME GOES AT
LEAST I WAS THE STATE. I JEWS
RETURNED FROM A TOUR ON FRIDAY
AT THE TAHOE CONSERVANCY WHICH
COMES OF THAT THE RESOURCE
AGENCY AND THERE'S A NEW REPORT
WHICH I HAVEN'T READ BUT- IT'S
IN MY BY MY DESK. THAT SAYS
THAT. IN IN THE TAHOE AREA. WE
ONE EIGHT OF. HAS THE EXACT
SAME CARBON SEQUESTRATION
BENEFIT AS RECLAIMING AN ACRE
IN THE AMAZON- FOR SO I KNOW
PEOPLE WILL LOOK AT AMAZON
CRAZY AND I WON'T GET INTO A
DISCUSSION ON THE OFFSETS FROM
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM WHICH
IS ANOTHER CONCERN WITH THE
AIRPORT BUT I THINK PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE AND APPRECIATE.
THE VALUE OF THIS OF THE
WORKING LANDS AND THE AND THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE PROPER
REHABILITATION OF THAT SO MIGHT
MY HOPE WITH THAT YOUR
LEGISLATION IS THAT IS THAT
THERE IS IT THERE IS THIS THIS-
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE-
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND WE GET
ON THE SAME PAGE WITH THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE HERE SO
ALL. OF THE BILL MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR-
OF THE- ADDITIONAL FIVE
QUESTIONS FACING THEN THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
CASKEY I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
ON THIS ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
TAKING THE MAN'S THERE ARE A
LOT OF. CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES
HANGING OUT- AROUND THIS BILL-
BUT I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE-
THE GENERAL TRAJECTORY YOU'RE
TAKING HERE AND- WILL CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. SO I. AND I
ALSO UNDERSTAND YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO NEGOTIATE WITH. OUR
OPPOSITION AND CONCERNED FOLKS
ON VARIOUS- IN VARIOUS PLACES
ON THE ON THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM SEVEN. WITH THAT- THE
BILL HAS MOVED BY CENTER TASK
IF YOU LOOK CLOSE AND JUST
REALLY APPRECIATING GAUGE
MEANT- BY STAFF AND RESPECT
THAT'S WHEN I LOOK OKAY THANK
YOU. CONSULTAS COLOR ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE BATES. EIGHT
ZERO DALLY. GONZALEZ SKINNER
STERN Y. CASKEY HI CASKEY I.
OKAY OF. THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU.
WELL WE ARE OPEN FOR THE FOLKS
AT ON AND. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
NOW TO CRISTINA GARCIA THIS
ITEM THREE THIS IS AB SEVEN
THIRTEEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WITH. THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IS YOUR AGENDAS
NUMBERS THIS HAS TO DO WITH OUR
AIRBNB. POMERANTZ LLP ANNOUNCES.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READING
YOUR MESSAGE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB SEVEN
THIRTEEN REQUIRES THE STATE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO CONDUCT A
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH ANALYSIS
INCORPORATED INTO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SCHOOL BEING
PLANNED WHICH THEY UPDATE EVERY
FIVE YEARS AND HELPS US HELPS
GUIDE US AS WE REDUCE GHG
EMISSIONS AND IMPROVE AIR
QUALITY I DIDN'T HEALTH METRIC
IS NOT NEW TO AIR B. BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN THE BOARD DIRECTED
STAFF TO PROVIDE HEALTH
METRICS. THE NEXT COPING PLAN
WHICH IS DUE IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE UNFORTUNATELY EVEN THOUGH
CAR HAS WORKED WITH CD H. P. TO
INCLUDE THIS INFORMATION A
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH ANALYSIS
IS NOT PLANNED TO BE PART OF
THE NEXT SCHOOL BEING PLAN
WHICH WE SHOULD ALL BE- WE
SHALL FIND TROUBLING. I THINK
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT GHGS AND
CLIMATE CHANGE OUR COMMUNITIES
GET IT BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
IT'S ABOUT OUR HEALTH AT THE
END OF THE DAY AND ENSURING
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
HEALTHIER AND HAVING AN HONEST
CONVERSATION WITH OUR COMMUNITY
AFTER TRYING TO MAKE PROGRESS
IN THE STATE AND THE SPACE. AND
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE I HAVE A COUPLE
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY. THAT WILL FILL IN SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION- BY.
WHEN YOU GUYS WIN THE RUDOLPH
FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE AND ALSO- WILLIAM
BARRETT FROM THEIR ECONOMIC
SUFFICIENT. YES THANK YOU OKAY
LET'S GO WHEN WE GO TO MISREAD
ALL FIRST- THE COASTLINE. GOOD
MORNING I'M DR LINDA RUDOLPH OF
PHYSICIAN WORKING FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND THE
MEDICAL SOCIETY CONSORTIUM ON
CLIMATE AND HEALTH FORMALLY A
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER IN A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND EIGHTY SEVEN
ONE THREE PHYSICIANS KNOW THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALREADY
AFFECTING THE HEALTH OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. THE ROBUST
COOK COULD NOT BE COMPLETED.
IT'S VITAL FOR HELP. HELLO
CAMPERS HE'S PROPERTY. BUT BASS
COULD POLICY WILL COME
SIGNIFICANT RAPID HELP BENEFITS
AND REDUCED HEALTH CARE COSTS.
UNDER G. GREEN CARDS REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION. AND HEART LUNG
DISEASE MORE WALKING AND BIKING
REDUCE HEART DISEASE OBESITY
AND DIABETES. URBAN FORESTRY
REDUCES THE RISK OF HEAT
ILLNESS BUT CLIMATE POLICY CAN
ALSO WORSEN HEALTH HOME
WEATHERIZATION CAN WORK INDOOR
AIR QUALITY CAP AND TRADE CAN
PERPETUATE HEALTH INEQUITY.
CALIFORNIA WILL SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY ON CLIMATE CHANGE AB
SEVEN ONE THREE WILL PROVIDE
POLICY MAKERS THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO ENSURE THAT YOU
CLIMATE INVESTMENT OPTIMIZED
HEALTH BENEFITS AND MINIMIZE
HEALTH RISKS. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN ONE THREE
TWO INSURE THE CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE POLICIES PROTECT HELP.
AND PROMOTE HEALTH EQUITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LET'S NOW TO A
WILLIAM FOR THE AMERICA LUNG
AND. THANK YOU VERY UCH A GOOD
MORNING I AM WILL THERE AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF CLEAN AIR
ADVOCACY FOR THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ALSO SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT INFALLING DOCTOR
RUDOLPH'S COMMENTS A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH EVALUATION
OF THE SCOPING PLAN HAS BEEN A
LONG STANDING PRIORITY FOR LONG
ASSOCIATION AND MANY HEALTH
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE PAST
AND CURRENT PLANS. AND MANY OF
THOSE FOLKS I BELIEVE WE'RE ON
THE LINE AS WELL TODAY. WE DO
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO SCOPING
PLANS A CRITICAL EFFORT TO
CHART CALIFORNIA'S COURSE
RAPIDLY AWAY FROM HARMFUL
FOSSIL FUELS AND TECHNOLOGIES
WE'RE ENGAGING NOW IN THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD PROCESS AND
SHARE THAT AGENCIES PUBLIC
HEALTH FOCUSED MISSION. THERE
IS NO QUESTION THAT THIS COULD
BE PLAN IS A KEY MILE MARKER IN
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE LEADERSHIP
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO SCOPINGPLAN WILL RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
ACTIONS AND INVESTMENTS TO BE
UNDERTAKEN OVER THE COMING
DECADE TO RETURN HELPS PROTECT
THE CLIMATE STANDARDS. THIS
BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT THE PLAN
IS DEVELOPED CURFEW LIKE BOTH
INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL EXPERTISE
TO EVALUATE THE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS AND BENEFITS OF THE
SCOPING PLAN AND ASSOCIATED
STRATEGIES TO FOLLOW. THE BILL
ALSO CALLS FOR CARP TO
DETERMINE WHAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WOULD BE NEEDED TO
ADVANCE A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS. IF THOSE TOOLS ARE
NOT CURRENTLY AVAILABLE.THIS
PROCESS CAN HELP. REALLY TO
IDENTIFY POLICIES MIGHT NEED TO
BE PRIORITIZED. AND YEAH VERY
IMPORTANTLY TO HELP THE AGENCY
BETTER HOME. TO HELP PROTECT OF
MEDICATIONS THAT WILL BE
NEEDED. WITHIN THE INDIVIDUAL
RULE MAKING PROCESS IS AN
INVESTMENT THAT FOLLOW. THE
ADOPTION OF THE SCOPING PLAN.
THAT THE BOTTOM LINE REALLY IS
THAT AS CAR MOVES INTO THE
TWENTY TRYING TO SCOPING PLAN
FULL BORE. ALONG WITH THOSE
FUTURE ITERATIONS OF THIS
GOVERNMENT PLAN A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH ANALYSIS.
WILL REALLY ALLOW FOR DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WAYS THAT
THE POLICIES MIGHT INTERACT
WITH. THEIR QUALITY PUBLIC
HEALTH HEALTH EQUITY ESPECIALLY
IN OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- WITHOUT ALL
CLOSING DESERVE YOUR AYE VOTE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OUR FOLKS WHO WANT
TO SUPPORT THE BILL I DON'T SEE
YOU HERE IN PERSON- ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES. WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI. SEVEN
THIRTEEN. SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
SEVEN THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY MORNING
BIRTH THIS IS JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND AND SUPPORT. A LINE NINETY
SIX YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS SO THEY RAN BOTH
WITH THE COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR IN SUPPORT. ONLINE EIGHTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING BILL MURPHY FOR THREE
FIFTY SILICON VALLEY AND THE
ELDERS CLIMATE ACTIONS NOR CAL
IN SOCAL CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT.
FIFTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. DR
ROBERT SCHOOL PRESIDENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO BAY PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PRESENTING COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS MEASURE. SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS DOCTOR
ASHLEY MCCLURE A PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN AND- COFOUNDER WITH
CRIME AND HEALTH NOW AND
ORGANIZATION AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ACROSS THE STATE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
ONE THREE THANK YOU. WHY NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY ONE
YOU ARE THIS IS KARENA
MERRIMENT PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS
ANGELES AND A MEMBER OF THE
CLIMATE HELP NOW GROUP OF OVER
FIVE HUNDRED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS I'M A PHYSICIAN
OF OBLIGATION AS IF THE PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF CHILDREN I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN
ONE THREE. THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. FOR AB
SEVEN THIRTEEN ANALYZING
THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. ONE
SHERMAN OVER ARE YOU AMMONIUM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORTER AB
SEVEN ONE THREE THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVEN'T WON WITH AN OPERATOR
ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR. I'M
I'M JUST. I'M SO SORRY I DIDN'T.
WHAT DO YOU SAY. I JUST SAID
THAT THERE WAS ONE OF AN
OPERATOR AND THEY HAVE IT NOW
IT'S LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
CONTACT OKAY GREAT. MORNING-
THANK YOU ANYTHING ELSE. HI
AFTER JOHN REPORT OF A SEVEN
TEXAS. THERE'S NO ELSE BUT THIS
TIME AND HAS A GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR CALLING
IN. FIVE NOW LET'S GO TO ANY
OPPOSITION I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
ANY. REGISTERED LEAD OPPOSITION
AND NO VERSION OF THE SYSTEM.
IN GENERAL- BUT IS THERE
ANYONE. TEMA IN PERSON IN
EITHER THE ROOMS AS ANYONE WHO
HAS CALLED THE INTEREST
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL MODERATOR. EXPRESS YOUR
OPPOSITION FOR AB SEVEN THIRTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY IS GOING UP AT
THIS TIME SIR OKAY. ALL RIGHT
WILL WHAT'S COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
CONCERNS THOUGHTS FROM THE
MEMBERS. WERE YOU ON THIS BILL
MY ADVICE HERE. REALLY GOOD.
BUT I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT THE
OTHER SIDE OF IT. WE MAKE OUR
CAR BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT MY
MAJOR CONCERN ALWAYS ASM MANNER
WHICH THEY COME OUT WITH KIND
OF DRACONIAN POLICIES WITH NOT.
THE APPROPRIATE PUBLIC INPUT ON
SOME OF THE IMPACTS SO I'LL
MAKE A COURTESY MOTION TO MOVE
IT AND THEN ALL OF STAND FOR
NOW OKAY. QUESTIONS I CAN ASK
MY- STAFF TO COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO OKAY THANK YOU
THIRTY MINIMALISM I'M I'M VERY
MUCH RESPECT YOUR PERSPECTIVE
I'M I'M CERTAINLY- VERY SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IN MAY I THINK
THAT- YEAH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS OF CLIMATE ACTION- AND
OF COURSE THE COST OF INACTION
ARE ARE MASSIVELY UNDERVALUED
CURRENTLY IN THIS CONVERSATION
SO I'M I'M- I'M IN. SHE THERE'S
BEEN TIES BACK TO CERTAIN FORMS
OF CANCER ALL OF THAT IS GOOD
BUT IT CAN'T BE ANECDOTAL I
MEAN THEY REALLY HAVE TO DO A
DEEP DIVE MAY NOT COME BACK
WITH THESE DRACONIAN POLICIES
AND GOT TO STOP EVERYTHING AND
THEY DO THAT WITHOUT A LOT OF
PUBLIC INPUT THOSE ARE THE
COMPLAINTS WE GET FROM- YOU
KNOW OUR DISTRICTS ZERO SOUTH.
COUNTY SOUTH OF. REGIONAL WATER
QUALITY BOARDS ON ALL OF THEM.
THEY JUST NEED TO. HELLO MORE
BALANCES WHAT I FEEL SO THIS IS
THE GOAL. AND IN VALUE FOR
NOBLE ONE. FROM IF YOU WERE
MINE WILL LOOK AT SOME OF THE
OTHER. PROBLEMS WITH. CARD
HOLDER. YEAH I'M THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULDN'T MIND RESPONDING TO
THE MEISTER'S COMMENTS IN YOUR
CLOTHES- AND I APPRECIATE THAT
BUT WITH THAT- MONITORED YOU
FOR YOUR CLOSE. THAT WE KNOW
THAT AT A MINIMUM ASTHMA HEART
DISEASE AND DIABETES ARE
SERIOUS HEALTH ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN TIED TO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THIS IS
PROPORTIONALLY AFFECTING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR COLORS
COMMITTEES LIKE MY COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN ALSO.
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
WITH THE CODE PANDEMIC IN THE
RESPIRATORY ISSUES THAT ARE.
THERE AND THAT'S NOT A
COINCIDENCE- WE'RE NOT ASKING
FOR AND IT'LL ACTUALLY ASKING
FOR A COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
ANALYSIS THAT BRINGS TOGETHER
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTISE.
SCIENTIFIC DATA AND
STAKEHOLDERS- AND PETIT VALLEY
THE POTENTIAL HEALTH EFFECTS
THAT PROPOSED POLICY. CHANGES I
THINK IN THE SAME WAY THAT YOU
WORRY ABOUT ONE THING THAT
BEING TAKEN SERIOUSLY. MY
COMMUNITY HAS ALSO FELT LIKE WE
ARE NOT TAKEN SERIOUSLY WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE HEALTH ISSUES
AND- WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THE
CLUSTERS THAT WE SEE OF YOU
KNOW IF. OF PEOPLE WITH CANCER
WITH THAT'S MY WE WERE LED TO
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE CRAZY
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS UP
THERE. SO I THINK IN THAT
RESPECT WE WANT TO SINGLE YOU
WANT WE WANT ANALYSIS BASED ON
DATA FAXES THAT WE CAN' BE
DISMISSED. ANYMORE OUT THERE
AND THAT AS WE'RE PUSHING
POLLUTION- SOLUTIONS BOARD THAT
WE'RE TAKING EVERYTHING INTO
EFFECT INCLUDING THE COST OF
INACTION. WHEN IT COMES TO HELP
OUT THERE AND THEN THE
INEQUITIES THAT WE LIVE WITH ON
A REGULAR BASIS- AND MY
COMMUNITY. AND SO I THINK THAT-
THIS BILL IS JUST ASKING AIR BE
TO THEIR JOB A LITTLE BIT
BETTER- OUT THERE AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ENABLE.
GROWTH THANK YOU. BRIDGES ARE
ALL RIGHT I'M CONSULTANT PLEASE
ROTH. ADAM FOUR AB SEVEN THREE
BY SOME CHRIS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN. HI ALLEN AYE BATES.
EIGHT STAINED DALLY AND SALAS
SKINNER STERN MY CASKEY.
ASSEMBLY REVIEW IN MY AND I'M
CONSIDERING ADDING ME ON AS A
CO AUTHOR AND PROJECT THAT'S
DEFINITELY LOVE TO HAVE YOU
ADDED ON OKAY THANK YOU SEE
THAT THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU.
DONNA MESS OF THE AMENDMENTS
BUT- I KNOW THE THINGS GO.
YOU'RE A. YEAH I GOT OKAY OKAY
OUR- MAKE SURE TO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE THE BY CHAIR THE
MOMENT. SOME OKAY FANTASTIC
ALRIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE TO
SOMEONE REALLY WHO'S HERE. AND
HE'S ALREADY GOT SOMEONE LINED
UP TO TESTIFY. WASTING NO TIME
I APPRECIATE THAT OKAY SO LET'S
GO TO ITEM SIX IS AB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO. AND WILL TURN TO YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS- ONE
APPRECIATE ALSO THE COMMITTEE'S
ATENTION AND WORK ON THIS BILL
AS WELL AS CENTER WORK
HOUSEKEEPING A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS THIS BILL ACTUALLY STEMS
FROM A CONSTITUENCY ISSUE IN
BOTH OUR SHARE POSITION SEEM
FREMONT- EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY
WILL ENSURE THAT PRIVATE AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE BUILT IN
SAFE LOCATIONS. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE GROUP OF PARENTS AND
STUDENTS FROM MY DISTRICT
FREMONT WEAPONS SO SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE AB SEVEN SIXTY
REQUIRES PRIVATE AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS MEET THE SAME SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS AS PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WHEN CHOOSING A NEW SCHOOL SITE
IN MY DISTRICT A PRIVATE SCHOOL
CALLED STRATFORD SCHOOL WAS
BUILT RIGHT NEXT TO CONCRETE
FACTORY. DOES THE CONTAMINANTS
FROM THE FACTORIES POSE A
DANGER TO THE HEALTH OF
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS. CHANGE
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PUT THEIR
HEALTH AT RISK BY GOING TO
CLASS. AND I WILL BE TAKING
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE EDUCATION
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES MENTIONED
IN THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS.
GINGER THE BILL APPLIES TO
PRIVATE AND CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO SEE WHAT. AB
SEVEN SIX TWO SIX PROTECTIONS
FROM AIR POLLUTION AND
DANGEROUS CHEMICALS. AND YOU'LL
HEAR FROM ME WITNESSES ALLEN
ABS FROM THE- BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY. HUNDRED DISTRICT. AND
ALSO ON THE PHONE WE'LL HEAR
FROM SHANNON SHALL WHO IS A
FORMER STUDENT AT STRATFORD
SCHOOL STRICTLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
DECEMBER ALL RIGHT. SO LET'S GO
TO ALLEN ABS FROM BAY AREA.
QUALITY MANAGEMENT. DISTRICT
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
ALAN ABSOLUTE SLAVE OFF THROUGH
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT THE SPONSOR
OF AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO. WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAVE FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TO PROTECT
CHILDREN'S HEALTH. IN CURRENT
LAW PRIOR TO CONSTRUCTING A NEW
PUBLIC SCHOOL OR PUBLICLY
FUNDED CHARTER SCHOOL. SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
PERFORM SEVERAL ACTS OF DUE
DILIGENCE TO BETTER ENSURE THE
HEALTH OF THEIR FUTURE STUDENTS
AND SCHOOL STAFF. THEY
DETERMINE THAT THE PROPERTY TO
BE BUILT UPON IS NOT A CURRENT
OR FORMER HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE.
OR HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE RELEASE
SITE AND THEY CONSULT WITH
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES MAKE A
FINDING THAT THE HEALTH RISKS
OR OTHER POLLUTION SOURCES DO
NOT AND WILL NOT CONSTITUTE. AN
ACTUAL OR POTENTIAL ENGAGEMENT
A PUBLIC HEALTH TO PERSONS WHO
WOULD ATTEND OR BE EMPLOYED AT
THE SCHOOL. THIS INCLUDES
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT. TO
IDENTIFY BOTH PERMITTED AND NON
PERMITTED FACILITIES WITHIN
THAT DISTRICTS AUTHORITY.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
FREEWAYS AND OTHER BUSY TRAFFIC
CORRIDORS LARGE AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS. RAILYARDS WITHIN
ONE FOURTH OF A MILE THE
PROPOSED SCHOOL SITE THAT MIGHT
REASONABLY BE ANTICIPATED TO
ADMIT HAZARDOUS AIR EMISSIONS.
THIS IS A REQUIREMENT THE
CURRENTLY DOES NOT APPLY TO
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND SOME
CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND WHILE
WE'RE NOT CLAIMING THAT A LARGE
NUMBER OF THE SCHOOLS ARE
POORLY CITED. INCREASING LAND
USE DENSITY AND RE PURPOSING
INFILL SITES RAISES THE
POSSIBILITY THAT WITHOUT
SIMILAR DUE DILIGENCE. FUTURE
SCHOOLS MAY BE CONSTRUCTED IN
THE VICINITY OF POLLUTION
SOURCES THAT UNNECESSARILY
EXPOSE CHILDREN AND EMPLOYEES.
TO UP ON HEALTHY WORK
ENVIRONMENT. AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO
REQUIRES THE SCHOOL AUTHORITIES
TO ASSESS THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
AND AIR POLLUTION CONDITIONS ON
AND IN THE VICINITY OF THE
PROPOSED SCHOOL. TO OF
KNOWLEDGE THIS INFORMATION AND
IF NECESSARY TO USE THEIR
DECISION MAKING. WHEN
CONSTRUCTING THEIR SCHOOL ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA AT&T IBM
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I. THE FOOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALL RIGHT. NEXT LET'S GO TO-
CHEN XIAO FROM STRAFFORD
SCHOOL. FORMER STUDENT FORMER
SUPERSTAR SERVICE CO. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SHANNON
SHALL AND I'M A PREVIOUS
TRAFFORD STUDENT WHO ATTENDED
THE FREMONT OSGOOD TRACKER
CAMPUS. GREAT BECAUSE OF THE
CONCRETE CEMENT PLANT POLLUTION
I HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO MOVE TO
ANOTHER SCHOOL IN SEVENTH
GRADE. FOR THE WHOLE YEAR AND
SIXTH GRADE YOU'RE INHALING
DUST THE EMPLOYEES AIR COMBAT
CHICHI ARE CONCRETE CEMENT
PLANT RIGHT NEXT TO TRAPPERS
SCHOOL WHEN WE ARE PLAYING
OUTDOORS. YOU WERE LOCKED DOWN
INSIDE THE BUILDING BECAUSE WE
WERE TOLD THERE WAS A DUSTY
STORM BLOWING SHE SHE OUR
CEMENT PLANT. WE WERE SITTING
IN A CLASSROOM WITH LIMITED
NATURAL LIGHT BECAUSE THE
TEACHERS ARE CEMENT PLANTS
TRUST IN AN ACTIVITY RIGHT NOW
SACRAMENTO. I SUPPORT EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO BECAUSE IT WILL
PREVENT OTHER STUDENTS LIKE ME
FROM EXPERIENCING ON TACKLING
FROM SIMILAR THINGS. EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO WILL MAKE SURE.
THAT SCHOOLS ARE NOT BUILT NEAR.
SOURCES OF ERICA. SECOND CONG
PLANS SO THAT STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS LEARN AND HEALTHY IN
SAFE AND- I THINK YOU. REQUEST
A- TO SUPPORT EIGHTY. SIX TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
OUR LET'S GO TO SEE. FOR THE
BILL AND I DON'T SEE WHERE
PERSON BE ON DONE. OUR BUT MR
ABSOLUTES NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE ELSE YOU WANT TO
WEIGH THEIR WAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THIS IS AB SEVEN SIXTY
TWO ON THE PHONE LINES. THE
CORRECT CARE EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR A BI A SEVEN SIXTY TWO
PLEASE RESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND WE WERE LINE FIFTEEN.
GOOD MORNING MISS INSURING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHNSON PLAN
ABOUT HALF OF THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
SIX TWO. ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING SURE
MEMBERS I'M NOT SURE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION COURT THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTY ONE HEY EXCUSE ME LINE
EIGHTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT OR- ONE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS. ONE OF
THREE ARE OPEN. ONE MORE CHANCE
ONE OH THREE ARE YOU MUTED.
WILL BE ONLINE SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AS A
PARENT I'M NOT FORTY SUPPORT.
SB SEVEN SIXTY TWO NINE THE
SHALL MOM. ONE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT EVEN WHEN
I AM FULLY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN SIXTY TWO. LINE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SECURING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TIMELY I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION-
CAPCO. BEGINNING AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS FROM ALL
THIRTY FIVE- DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE. I'LL BE HAPPY CAP THOSE
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE
RESPECTFULLY URGE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO DO SO AS WELL
THANK YOU. BY NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MISTER
SHARE MEMBERS NICK WRONGLY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
I JUST WANNA QUICKLY NO WE ARE
LISTED AS OPPOSITION IN THE
ANALYSIS BUT WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US AND-
PLEASED TO SAY WE ARE NOW GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD THANKS AGAIN TO THE
AUTHOR AND UP. CORPORATE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND AGAIN I
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR. AB ARE
SEVEN SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND LINE
ONE OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M CHANDEL SHELL AND I'M A
FORMER STRAFFORD SCHOOL STUDENT
AND I SUPPORT BILL AB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO. LINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CRYSTAL DYING AND
I'M NOT FORMER US SHOPPERS
SCHOOL PARENTS AND NON. WORK
WITH THE B. SEVEN SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU. FIVE ONE OH SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
OF SIX. A GOOD MORNING- THIS IS
A MAKE YOU CAN BETTER ON THE
COURT OF THE. EIGHTY SEVEN SIX
TWO. THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL AND
LEAD OPPOSITION HAVE ERIC MAX
FROM CHURCH SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER. FOLLOWED BY JOHN WENGER
WHO IS SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION. GOOD MORNING MR
TERRIO CONNECT WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT CENTER.
REPRESENTING SEVERAL HUNDRED
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. REACH OF THIS BILL
IN ITS CURRENT AMENDED FORMAT
IT'S EXPANDED QUITE A BIT FROM
ITS ORIGINAL FOCUS ON AIR
QUALITY AND NOW IMPOSES. A
COMPLICATED TANGLE OF LAWS.
THAT WILL MAKE IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO ACQUIRE HIGH
QUALITY SAFE PROPERTIES. SHAPE
PROPERTIES AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
MOVED VERY QUICKLY IN
CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVE REAL
ESTATE MARKET. IN THIS BILL
WILL HAVE THE UNINTENDED.
EFFECT OF ACTUALLY MAKING
FACILITIES LESLIE- CHARTER
SCHOOL STUDENTS RATHER THAN
MORE FOR THOSE AND OTHER
REASONS WE ASK THAT YOU OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO A JOHN LANGER WHO'S
NEXT. THANK YOU MISTER
SHURMUR'S JOHN LINGER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION-
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS FOR THE
CONTINUED DIALOGUE BUT WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME. UNLESS IT IS AMENDED
TO ADDRESS SOME OF OUR KEY
ISSUES- FIRST OF ALL TO GET
STATE SUPPORTS ALL STUDENTS
HAVING ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
SAFE AND ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND
EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES. AND
NATIONALLY INTRODUCED YET THEY
HAD NO POSITION ON A. B. SEVEN
SIXTY TWO HOWEVER WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE IMPOSED IN
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE- WE BELIEVE THAT
pUNWORKABLE UNWORKABLE AND
INEQUITABLE AND WOULD LIMIT
EDUCATIONAL ACCESS FOR MANY
HIGH NEED STUDENTS UNDER
CURRENT EDUCATION CODE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED TO MEET
ALL THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODE. IN
ACQUIRING OR DEVELOPING
FACILITIES HOWEVER CHARTER
SCHOOL DO NOT HAVE ACCESS. TO
RESOURCES THAT DISTRICTS DO. SO
JUST LOCKED LOW BONDING
AUTHORITY LOCAL THE EXEMPTIONS
IN EMINENT DOMAIN AUTHORITY
THERE FOR CITING AND
DEVELOPMENT. OF DISABILITIES
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS. CHARTER
SCHOOL USE AND PROTECT THIS
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING
COMPARED TO DISTRICT PROJECTS
BECAUSE OF THE CHALLENING THAT
BECAUSE OF THESE CHALLENGES
ADDING NEW REQUIREMENTS BEYOND
THE EXISTING RIGOROUS STANDARDS
OF THE- CALIFORNIA BUILDING
CODE. SHOULD BE ONLY DONE WHEN
A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED UNFORTUNATELY THE-
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION ARE
OVERLY EXCESSIVE INTO CLICK
DUPLICATE THEIR- FOR THE
PROSTITUTES CHARTER SCHOOLS
HAVE AT THE STATE LEVEL. IN A
MANNER THAT WILL BE INEFFICIENT
AND COSTLY AND WILL NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THESE
FACILITIES- WE BELIEVE THESE
AMENDMENTS SEARCH ARE NOT
JUSTIFIED TO GO BEYOND THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE BILL- WE
WOULD FURTHER NOTE THAT THE
BILL SHOULD BE AMENDED TO
PROVIDE A REASONABLE
GRANDFATHERING PROVISIONS
PROTECT. EXISTING SCHOOLS
SCHOOLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPMENT
UNDER THE EXISTING RULES. ARE
CHANGING THE RULES IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PROJECT- IT WOULD
BE AT SIGNIFICANT LOSS TO
COMMUNITIES WHERE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE INVESTING.
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES AND COULD
RESULT IN ALL. LACK OF ANY-
QUALITY SOLUTION PROGRAMS IN
THESE COMMUNITIES- WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND- THE JURISDICTIONAL
ISSUES- BETWEEN SEVENTY Q. AND
WE EDUCATION COMMITTEE BUT
GIVEN THAT THESE AMENDMENTS
WERE WERE FAIRLY RECENT WE DID
FEEL. OBLIGATED TO GO ON RECORD
AND OPPOSE- THE RECENT LANGUAGE
AND WE. LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. LET'S SEE IF
THIS ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE. TO
WEIGH IN IN OPPOSITION OR RAISE
CONCERNS. ARE YOU OUT FOR THE
PHONE LINES MISTER CHAIR YES
EXACTLY THE FROM A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OUT TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR A BE A SEVEN SIX
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. HI MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S NOBODY QUEUEING
UP OKAY. GREAT ARM. THE ITEM IS
I BACK BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND DOUBTS AND
CONCERNS- I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY THE CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION AMONG. THE TO-
OPPOSITION WITNESSES I THINK
MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE I
WILL BE OPPOSING IT BUT IF YOU
NEED A COURTESY MOTION NOW WE
CAN CERTAINLY DO THAT SO WE
MOVED ON AND SO THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OF KNOWS HE'S
GOT A MOTION HARD ON THE FLOOR
FOR THE WE CAN ALSO IF YOU LIKE
WE CAN ALSO. DO MOTION WE GET
EVERYONE HERE OKAY. MAYBE
THAT'S BETTER BECAUSE I WILL
NEED TO OPPOSE IT TODAY THE
IDEA- YEAH I KNOW AND YOU KNOW
THIS IS A TRICKY THING BECAUSE
THE MEN MEN MEN SAID YOU. ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT MEADOW VICE
CHAIR- WERE RAISED WE'RE WE'RE
PUT IN. ON EDUCATION THEY
REALLY TO THE EDUCATION BECAUSE
THEYRE NOT REALLY WITHIN THE
PURVIEW JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE. AND YET THEY DO- IF
FOR REASONS THAT ARE TOTALLY
ALMOST. REFERRAL TO THE CORE
GOALS ARE YOUR GOALS YOUR BILL
AND- THEY THEY WERE THEY WERE
ADDED AND SO- YEAH. IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME A HIGHER BAR TO
AFFECT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS FOR PERHAPS A
DIFFERENT REASONS THAN. WE
SHOULD BE INVOLVED WITH SO.
ANYWAY OKAY YEP YEAH I'M. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT- I YOU KNOW THIS THIS
REMINDS ME OF SOME OF MY
EXPERIENCES CHARITY KITCHEN
COMMITTEE- THE DION RUNNING
BATTLES NEVER NEVER SEEM TO
CEASE- ANYHOW WE WILL WE WILL
CERTAINLY ENTERTAIN MUCH LATER-
AND I. TOOK OFF IN THE BILL GET
OUT OF COMMITTEE HERE TODAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT- WOULD LIKE
TO IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT YOU KNOW THIS
BUILDING TOUCH THE BILL'S TO
ALIGN THE SANDERS WING ALL
SCHOOLS WHETHER OR NOT YOU SEND
YOUR CHILD TO A PRIVATE SCHOOL
PUBLIC SCHOOL OR A CHARTER
SCHOOL CERTAINLY YOU SHOULD NOT
WORRY ABOUT WHEN YOU DROP THEM
OFF ARE THEY GOING TO BE
EXPOSED TO HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
OR- HAS OR SUBSTANCES. YOU FOR
EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW INCLUDE A IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THERE'S A KID SOME HELP HELP
KIP SOCAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS PLAN
TO BUILD A CHARTER ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL ON A SITE WITH DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS IT ALL REPORT SHOWS
THAT THE SITE CONTAINS TALKS
SERVICES INCLUDING. INCLUDING
LEAD AND ARSENIC THE CHARTER
SCHOOL WAS NOT SUBJECT TO SEEK
OR OTHER REVIEWS A POTENTIALLY
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES BECAUSE A
LOOPHOLE. THAT WOULD BE CLOSE
OF THIS BILL. SO WE'RE HOPING
TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT CLOSING
THAT LOOPHOLE MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY CHILD NO MATTER THE
SCHOOL TO GO TO IS SAFE- AND
I'LL- HOPEFULLY GET VOTE. WHEN
YOU GET AN OPTION YEAH THANK
YOU. BRING PRISONERS STANDING-
OKAY. BUT YOU FOR MEMBER MULLIN
I SEE IT HERE. AND WILL PRESENT
AB EIGHT NINETY SEVEN. THANK
YOU SHARE MEMBERS AS YOU KNOW
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALREADY
AFFECTING CALIFORNIAN IS
ESTIMATED TO DO SO WELL INTO
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE. CURRENT
AND PROJECTED IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDE
INCREASED TEMPERATURE SEA LEVEL
RISE INTENSE WILDFIRES ALTERED
PRECIPITATION PATTERNS
EXCESSIVE FLOODING SEVERE
DROUGHT AND MORE FREQUENT STORM
EVENTS MANY IMPACTS WILL. VARY
BASED ON A COMMUNITIES PHYSICAL
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
CHARACTERISTICS WHICH TEND TO
EXTEND BEYOND CITY OR COUNTY
BOUNDARIES THIS MAKES REGIONAL
COORDINATION BETWEEN OR AMONG
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS.
CYLLENE C. PLANNING SOME LOCAL
ENTITIES ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
BEGUN THE PROCESS OF PREPARING
FOR THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE HOWEVER MANY ENTITIES
HAVE NOT BEGUN COORDINATING
THIS PREPAREDNESS WITH JASON
ENTITIES IN THE REGION AND SOME
HAVE NOT BEGUN PLANNING. AT ALL
I'M AFRAID TO DO THIS LACK OF
COORDINATED PLANNING THE
STATE'S CURRENT MECHANISM FOR
FUNDING ADAPTATION PROJECTS HAS
PRIMARILY BEEN PIECEMEAL. WITH
NO COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR
COORDINATING ITS INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
RESILIENCY RETURN THIS BILL AB
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN SEEKS TO
FILL THE GAP BY ENCOURAGING AND
SUPPORTING REGIONAL CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PLANNING THAT BUILDS
UPON AND ENHANCES LOCAL
ADAPTATION ACTIONS TO REDUCE
CLIMATE RISKS FOSTERING
COLLABORATION AMONG LOCAL
REGIONAL STATE ENTITIES ON
ADAPTATION SOLUTIONS. AND
FINALLY DEVELOPING GUIDANCE FOR
POTENTIAL STATE FEDERAL OR
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN FUNDING
REGIONAL PRIDE OR PRIORITY
ADAPTATION PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY ON THE PHONE BRUCE
WRITTEN WITH THE BAY AREA
CLIMATE ADAPTATION NETWORK AND
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROGER
DICKINSON WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION. THERE WE
GO OKAY WELL I DO WANT TO START
WITH THE MYSTERY OR- ADDICTED.
KEVIN THURMOND YOU WOULD YOU
WOULD YOU WE HAVE RESIDENTS IN
DOWN FIRST FOR YOU MENTIONED
THE PURSER AND FIRST YOU HAVE A
PREFERENCE IN ORDER. I'M SORRY
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME IS TO SAY ONE
MORE TIME. WE HAD. THIS IS NOT
A BIG DEAL WE HAD. A GREAT
SUMMER DICKINSON DOWN FIRST
BILL YOU MENTIONED REARED IN
FIRST DELAY PREFERENCE ARE GOOD
TO GO EITHER WAY OKAY. LET'S GO
WITH YOUR ORDER AYE BRUCE
REARED IN- FOR THE VERY CLIMATE
ADAPTATION NETWORK EITHER. YEAH
GOOD MORNING- CLIMBERS. THE
AREA CLIMBING NETWORK AND I
ALSO MANAGE THE CLIMATE READY
DISTANCE YOU'D UC BERKELEY
SUCKS GOOD MORNING SURE ALLEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I SPEAK OF
THIS MORNING IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT NINE SEVEN MINUTES YOUR
VERY AWARE WERE NOW FACE TO
FACE HERE CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS
THE GLOBE WITH SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS ON WATER GLOBAL CLIMATE
RECORD WILDFIRES RECORD DROUGHT
RECORD HEAT WAVES YOU SAW THE
NORTHWEST THIS WEEKEND CANADA
BY THE WAY THAT- SATURDAY SEVEN
ALL TIME RECORDS HOTTEST
TEMPERATURE EVER IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. AND IN THE NOT TOO
FUTURE HERE AND ALONG THE COAST
RECORD HE WILL RIGHTS COMING IN
RECORDS LEVINE BUT THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT NUMBERS OR HEADLINE
ALTHOUGH WE'RE GETTING- OF THE
IMPACT ARE AND WILL BE REALLY
SUBSTANTIAL ON PEOPLE ON HUMAN
HEALTH- ON IN ADDITION NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS ON A
INFRASTRUCTURE MORE TO DEAL
WITH ALL OF THAT LET'S HEARING
COMING IN A BIG WAY WE NEED A
TRULY INTEGRATED AND WELL
FUNDED. CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROGRAM WE NEED A STRUCTURE
THAT BRINGS TOGETHER THE STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL RESOURCES IN
A MANNER VERY EQUITABLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE MANNER AND WE
BELIEVE THAT EIGHT NINE SEVEN
BY FOCUSING ON REGIONAL
ADAPTATION PLANNING IS A BIG
STEP OF CREATING THAT STRONG
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM THERE RIGHT
NOW CITIES AND COUNTIES WATER
DISTRICTS MANY OF WHICH WE WORK
WITH WITH A BAY CAN COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THEY'RE
ALREADY TAKING ACTION LOCALLY
TO BUILD LOCAL CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND A NINETY SEVEN
REAL PROMISES THAT IT WILL
BUILD UPON THESE EFFORTS. AND
HANDSOME I TIED THEM TOGETHER
IN A IN A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE WAY IF WE CAN
SKILLFULLY COMBINED THESE LOCAL
ADAPTATION EFFORTS WITH TRULY.
COLLABORATIVE REGIONAL PLANNING
NOT TO JUST GOVERNMENT AID. BUT
COMMUTER ORGANS ARE. OUR REGION
STAKE NOW ALL THE WE CAN COME
THOSE WITH SINCE. STATE FUNDING
AND- WE WILL BE IN THE SHAPE
OUR GOING AND CAL IS YOU KNOW.
YOU ARE STEVEN LEE THANKFULLY
GLOBALLY ON CUTTING CARBON
EMISSIONS FOR FIFTEEN OR MORE
YOU NOW IN HAPPEN BECAUSE HOPE.
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES UTILITIES
WOULD DO THE RIGHT THING THAT
HAPPEN BECAUSE YOU ALL HAVE
LAW. AB THIRTY TWO SB THIRTY
TWO AND ONE NINETY SEVEN THREE
SEVENTY FIVE ON AT ALL AND IT
HAPPENED BECAUSE WE SPENT REAL
STATE MONEY ON IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THE TIME IS
NOW. FOR CALIFORNIA IN THAT
SAME WAY TO BECOME THE GLOBAL
LEADER ON ADAPTATION FOR
CLIMATE AND RESILIENCE AND WE
SUPPORT EIGHT NINETY SEVEN AS
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
MOVEMENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. ALL OKAY THANK YOU HELLO
NOW GO TO RUN DICKINSON. YOU'RE
WELCOME. ROGER GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON ROGER
DICKINSON POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
AT THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ACCELERATE AND WORSEN
THE URGENCY FOR ADAPTATION
ACTION IT'S CLEARER NOW THAN
EVER BEFORE. CHEN ISNEEDED AT
ALL LEVELS TO SAFEGUARD OUR
ECONOMY INFRASTRUCTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH NATIONAL WORKING LANDS
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. RECENTLY LOCAL
ENTITIES BOTH GOVERNMENTAL AND
NON GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS. HAVE UNDERTAKEN
EFFORTS TO ACCEPT CLIMATE RISKS
AND VULNERABILITIES DEVELOP
ADAPTATION PLANS AND IMPLEMENT
STRATEGIES TO BUILD COMMUNITY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE RESILIENCE
ACROSS THE STATE HOWEVER THERE
REMAINS A CRITICAL NEED FOR
STATE RECOGNITION AND SUPPORT
FOR REGIONAL ADAPTATION
PLANNING COORDINATION AND
FUNDING. AFFECTED REGIONAL
COORDINATION AND PLANNING
REQUIRES BRINGING TOGETHER A
WIDE RANGE OF ORGANIZATIONS AND
INTEREST TO UNDERTAKEN SUPPORT
CLIMATE ADAPTATION EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN PROVIDE THE NEEDED
FLEXIBILITY FOR EACH REGION TO
DETERMINE THE MOST APPROPRIATE
FORM OF REGIONAL COLLABORATION
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT ITS
REGIONAL ADAPTATION PLANNING
EFFORTS. EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN WILL HELP EACH REGION
ACCELERATE THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF ADAPTATION STRATEGIES AND A
MORE STRATEGIC AND INCLUSIVE
MANNER WELL BUILDING LONGER
TERM CAPACITY AMONG AGENCIES
AND ORGANIZATIONS. BY HAVING P.
R. SUPPORT AND WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND REGIONS EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSES THE
NEED FOR A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH BETWEEN THE LOCAL AND
STATE LEVELS. THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE I
RESPECTFULLY URGE. YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU OKAY-
I DON'T BELIEVE SO I DON'T DO
WE HAVE ANY HERE IN PERSON OR
ANYONE- LET'S LOOK- ANYONE
TWENTY FORTY LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES ANYONE WANT TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR UP. FOR AB
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN MODERATOR.
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL
ALIGN NINETY THREE. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS PERSONAL CHAOS ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. NINE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR JAMES MICHAEL WITH
ADULTS DEAN GILBERT ROBESON
SMITH ON BEHALF OF SAM CISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ALSO IN SUPPORT. ONE ONE
THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS DIFFICULTY
ON BEHALF OF LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT OF
AB. EIGHT NINETY SEVEN. PINE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL THEN WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT
ABOUT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. BY
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRANCH OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. AND AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWEDBY
ZEROS SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT
NINE SEVEN AND SIXTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. I SIXTY FOUR IF YOU'D
LIKE TO RE QUEUE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO YOU MIGHT
AS- AN OVERLY TAKE YOURSELF OUT
OF Q. AND WITH A LINE EIGHTY
TWO. BILL MURPHY FOR THREE
FIFTY SILICON VALLEY AND ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTIONS NOR CAL IN
SOCAL CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT. NOW
LINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BREANNA KANNADA ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION AND
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. AND
NOBODY ELSE IS COMING UP MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY THANK YOU EVERYBODY
FOR COLIN AND- LET'S NOW I SEE
IF THERE'S ANYBODY LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL WE I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE- ANY WHICH
REALLY DON'T HAVE ANY- I WILL
RAISE IT UP AS AN ALL KNOWING
NO ONE CALLING AND IN
OPPOSITION AS ANYONE ON THE
LINE TO LIKE TO RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL BECAUSE I DON'T
SEE ONE IN PERSON. MODERATOR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TWO I'LL SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN. NOBODY
IS GIVING UP OKAY I MAKES SENSE
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS THOUGHTS.
SAN FERNANDO VICE CHAIR YES I
I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT IT.
THE REASON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN IT STARTS OUT IS BEING
QUITE PERMISSIVE AND READING IT
AND READING THE DIGEST HERE. IT
WOULD APPEAR ONCE YOU FORMED
THIS REGIONAL CLIMATE-
ORGANIZATION- THERE'S A
MANDATED APPROACH TO YOUR PLAN
THAT COMES THROUGH- PR AND- I
DON'T KNOW I JUST THINK THINGS
WITH WHEN THEY'RE NOT DEVELOPED
BASED ON. GOOD SCIENCE THAT'S
COME FROM SOME OTHER PLACE THAT
ARE HAVING- PR HERE AT THE
STATE ARE TELLING THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP THIS COME
TOGETHER LET'S JUST SAY IT'S
THE MPO HOW TO GO ABOUT
DESIGNING THEIR PLAN AND AN MPO
USUALLY IS DEALING MAINLY WITH.
TRANSPORTATION OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
CONNECTED HOUSING SIGNIFICANTLY
NOW SO I THINK THERE'S JUST A
LOT AREAS THAN IT THAT RAISE
CONCERNS FOR ME- HAVING BEEN A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BOTH COUNTY
AND CITY- THEY ARE THEY HAVE AN
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THEY DO HAVE
A LOT OF. PLANNING PEOPLE THEY
HAVE A LOT OF HEALTH PEOPLE OF
ALL THE THINGS THAT GO INTO
DETERMINING CLIMATE ADAPTATION
SO- JUST RELUCTANT TO SUPPORT.
IT IN ITS CURRENT FORM. TODAY.
OKAY- I GUESS SIMPLY STATED IT
SEEMS LIKE A MANDATE CAN FOLLOW
IT THEN THAT BECOMES AN ISSUE
OKAY FOR ME ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
IN MIND I RESPECT YOUR POSITION
WHAT WHY DON'T WE AND THEN WAIT
FOR ANOTHER MEMBER TO CONTACT
MOVE THE BILL- IF YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND OR ARE KIND OF PUTTING
US ON THE RECORD AT THE CLOSE I
WILL CERTAINLY BE SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY. IT WILL BE THAT
THAT IS A COMMON FAILURE
PRECIADO- MA'AM CENTER. WILL
LEAVE IT WITH THAT. ACTUALLY
I'M SORT OF A CASKEY IS MOVING
THE BILL. THE WORKERS WILL.
JUST IN TIME SO THERE WE GO. I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THAT THAT'S
YOUR CLOTHES OKAY RESPECT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE AND THANK
YOU CENTER Y. CASKEY WILL BE
WORK BUILDING ON THE WORK OF I
CARP- GOING FORWARD SELF. THANK
YOU FOR THE SECOND. THE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB EIGHT NINE
SEVEN I ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER.
ALAN HI ALAN I BATES. DALLY
GONZALEZ SKINNER STERN BY CAL
SKI HI LCI OKAY THANK YOU FOR
YOU MISTER MOM WE WILL AND
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHER FOLKS TO ADD ON. ALL
RIGHT WE ARE NEXT FIVE. FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CITY COM LOGGER
WHO IS PRESENTING AB NINE SIXTY
TWO. AREA SOME FAVOR MIND- YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY THE
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB NINE SIX TWO YES
SENATOR WOULD HAVE BE IT IS AN
A. B. BAIL. I FIRST LIKE TO SAY
THAT I AM ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. AB NINE
SIXTY TWO WILL PAVE THE WAY FOR
RETURNABLE BEVERAGE BOTTLE
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA BY
ALLOWING THESE PARTICULAR
MODELS TO FLOW THROUGH THE
CALORIE CYCLE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM.
RATHER THAN BEING CRASHED FOR
RECYCLING THESE BOTTLES CAN BE
PRESERVED TO BE WASHED AND
REFILLED BY BEVERAGE PRODUCER
SIMULTANEOUSLY CREATING JOBS
AND REDUCING WASTE. THE DATA
SHOWS CALIFORNIANS PURCHASE AN
AVERAGE OF TWO TO THREE
PACKAGED DRINKS EVERY DAY
ALMOST 1100% OF WHICH ARE IN
SINGLE USE GLASS PLASTIC METAL
AND PAPERBOARD BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS. THE LARGEST
CATEGORY OF THESE ARE BEVERAGES
COVERED. BY THE C. R. V. BOTTLE
BILL PROGRAM WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR
JUST OVER TWENTY FIVE BILLION
SINGLE USE CONTAINERS ANNUALLY
THAT IS SO MUCH WASTE. SO 7280%
OF THESE CONTAINERS ARE
RETURNED AND SUCCESSFULLY
RECYCLED INTO NEW CONTAINERS.
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND TONS OF SINGLE USE
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS ARE STILL
DISPOSED OF ANNUALLY IT IS A
WEIGHTY PROBLEM THAT IS NOT
GOING AWAY SOON. BUT THERE ARE
CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE COMPANIES
THAT ARE DOING THEIR PART BY
USING RETURNABLE BOTTLES.
MEANING THAT THESE FILES CAN BE
CLEANED WASHED AND THEN REUSED
THESE BOTTLES ARE THE MOST
SUSTAINABLE CHOICE FOR BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS AND THERE'S A
GROWING INTEREST IN USING MORE
GLASS RETURNABLE BOTTLES. I
LIKE TO THINK OF THE MILK MAN
YOU KNOW COMING BACK TWENTY
pKINDS OF BEVERAGES IN THOSE
GLASS BOTTLES. THE RETURNABLE
BOTTLES KEEP OUR AIR CLEAN OUR
BEACHES IN OUR PARKS AND
ROADSIDES LITTER FREE OR- YES
HOPEFULLY COMPLETELY A 100%
PROMOTE OF CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND-INCENTIVIZE A RENEWAL. OF
RETURNABLE GLASS SOMETHING THAT
WAS COMMON FORTY YEARS AGO.
LAST YEAR I VISITED ORGANS
RETURNABLE BOTTLE SYSTEM BOTTLE
DROP. WHERE THESE BOTTLES ARE
SORTED WASHED STERILIZED
INSPECTED AND DELIVERED BACK TO
CRAFT BEVERAGE PRODUCERS.
CALIFORNIA BASED BUSINESSES
HAVE STARTED USING GLASS
RETURNABLE BOTTLES. BUT THEY
ARE TAKING THEM OUT OF THE
STATE TO HAVE THEM WASHED
STERILIZED AND INSPECTED SO WE
ARE IN FACT TAKING BUSINESS OUT
OF THE STATE. AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGING A SECTOR-
IN THIS INDUSTRY ALSO TO GROW
AND EXPAND OUT OF THE STATE WHY
NOT CREATE A STATUTORY FIX WITH
EIGHTY NINE SIX TWO THAT WILL
ALSO CREATE SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL. BENEFITS LAST
WEEK THE STATEWIDE COMMISSION
ON RECYCLING ISSUED A UNANIMOUS
SEVENTEEN TO ZERO
RECOMMENDATION TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL SAYING THAT IT WOULD BE A
NECESSARY TOOL TO SUPPORT THIS
NEW AN ESSENTIAL WASTE
REDUCTION INFRASTRUCTURE. WITH
ME IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE MARK
MURRAY AND KIRK CAMELS TO
ANHEUSER BUSCH REGIONAL VP OF
STATE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND AT
THE TIME WHEN IT IS APPROPRIATE
I WILL BE RESPECTFULLY ASKING
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ARE ABLE
TO READ YOUR- WE WITNESS I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- MEMBERS MADAM VICE CHAIR
AS WELL I GUESS I'M NOT THE
QUITE THE MILKMAN BUT I
DEFINITELY WILL. BE YOUR MAN ON
THIS ONE- FOR KIMMEL SHOE AT
THE ANHEUSER BUSCH- IN HAZARD
BUSH OPERATES REFILLABLE
UNRETURNABLE SYSTEMS AROUND THE
WORLD I CLEARLY UNDERSTAND THE
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS- ADDED
THIS PROGRAM AND THE ADDITION
OF RETURNABLE BOTTLES TO THE
PROGRAM WOULD OFFER THE STATE-
ANHEUSER BUSCH HAS A 100% OF
OUR PACKAGING GOALS- BY THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO BE
MADE FROM A MAJORITY RECYCLED
CONTENT. OR CONTENT THAT IS
RETURNABLE WHICH IS WHY WE SEE
SUCH VALUE IN SENATOR KAMLAGER
PROPOSAL AT THE ADDITION OF
RETURNABLE BOTTLES TO THE
STATE'S RECYCLING PROGRAM
ADVANCES SUSTAINABILITY GOALS
NOT ONLY FOR A. B. BUT ALSO FOR
BEVERAGE PRODUCERS ACROSS THE
STATE AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED.
AN INCREASE IN RETURNABLE
BOTTLE OPERATIONS ALSO PUTS
CALIFORNIA ON A PATH. TO A
GREEN ECONOMY BY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL JOBS LOCAL
PRODUCTION OPTIONS AND LINE
WORKERS MANAGERS AND BOTTLE
COLLECTORS AS THE SENATOR
OUTLINED AND MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE JOBS STAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND SPEAKING OF THAT
RIGHT HERE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS POP
PARTICIPATED IN A PILOT PROJECT
THAT WE LAUNCHED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO TEST THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND THE DESIRE
FOR RETURNABLE BOTTLES. AND
WHAT I'M HAPPY TO REPORT IS THE
PILOTS PILOT SHOWED TREMENDOUS
POTENTIAL FOR THE FUTURE OF
RETURNABLE BOTTLES IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THAT REASON
THAT WE THANK THE SENATOR FOR
HER EFFORTS ON THIS AND HER
LEADERSHIP AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE. TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. BUT YOU.
OKAY LET'S GO TO MARK MARIN
ATOP WAY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARK MURRAY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE- WE
KNOW THAT A REFILLABLE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER HAS A LOWER CARBON
FOOTPRINT THAN A KICK CONTAINER
THAT IS USED ONCE. EVEN WHEN
THAT CONTAINERS RECYCLED IN A
70% RATE EVEN WHEN THAT
CONTAINER HAS 50% RECYCLED
MATERIAL IN BOTH OF WHICH IS
CURRENTLY THE CASE IN
CALIFORNIA- TODAY THERE ARE
GLASS BEVERAGE CONTAINERS BEING
MANUFACTURED IN RECYCLED
CALIFORNIA IT COULD BE WASHED
REFILLED. CENTER CALM WATERS
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY TWO WILL
UPDATE CALIFORNIA'S BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING RULES AND
INCENTIVES TO ALLOW THE STATE
EXPENSE THAT WORK A BUYBACK
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ACCEPT AND PAY REAP ON VALUE.
MODERATE RISK REUSABLE
CONTAINERS. TRANSPORTERS
CONTAINERS TO BE WASHED FOR
REDUCE RATHER THAN CRUSHED AND
RECYCLED. AND ALLOW BEVERAGE
PRODUCERS LIKE BEAR FLAG IN AND
HUNDRED PUSH TO REBUILD
CONTAINERS WE URGE AND I BOTH.
OKAY THANK YOU MARK OKAY SO
LET'S GO TO SEE THE DENNIS
WANTS TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL I KNOWN IN PERSON
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES YOU
WANT TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
A BI. NINE SIXTY TWO. SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE SIX TWO
PLEASE PRESS STAR FOLLOWED BY
ONE. STARFALL BY ONE FOR
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE SIX TWO
AND WE WILL LINE SIXTY FOUR. I
APOLOGIZE THAT'S ONE EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU TURN NUMBERS
NIKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. ONE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LARCOM GAP OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. I THE MORNING CARE
NUMBERS OF THE OFTEN WE HAVE
THE FOLLOWING CLIENTS CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT IT YOU CAN
FOR EXAMPLE NATIONAL ACTION
COUNCIL OPERATE AND
THOUGHTLESSNESS ADDITIONAL
BANKAMERICA ALL IN SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY TWO PLEASE GOING.
MORE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
MARIN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTY SIX. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER DURING THE FINAL
REPORT ON BEHALF OF OCEANIA
THANK YOU. ONE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NORTH
AMERICA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. NINE EIGHTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. GO AHEAD. EIGHTY ONE.
EIGHTY ONE FINAL CHANCE. ARE
YOU MUTED. I KNOW RESPONSIBLE
ONE ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN THESE LOBBYING
COALITION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THE BILL WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE ALSO REGISTERING
SEPARATE SUPPORT FOR HEAL THE
BAY. THANK YOU. ONE ONE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI- THIS
IS MIKE WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE
GLASS PACKAGING INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT. LINE ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS LIVE BORDER LOTTO WITH
ECONOMIC COUNTY LOCAL TASK
FORCE COMPLETE DIVERSION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WHINE EIGHTY TO
YOUR OPEN. PHIL MURPHY FOR
THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY AND
ELDERS CLIMATE ACTIONS NOR CAL
IN SOCAL CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT.
ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH GOOD MORNING DIANA
WINE AND CHAIR OF THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF.
NINE SIXTY TWO. LINE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CATHY SCHAEFER SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU WE GET
THEM BY ONE TWENTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS THINK HAND WITH
ZERO WASTE THE NORMAN IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ALBANY ON A ONE ON ONE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO REGIONAL
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE SIX TWO
AND LINE THIRTY YOUR UP. THIS
IS OUR SINGLE MOST PER
CONTAINER CYCLING INSTITUTE IN
THE COURT. FIND ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHRISTOPHER CHEN WITH
CORE THE CENTER FOR OCEANIC
AWARENESS RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION IN EMPHATIC SUPPORT.
ONE ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CAROLINE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NEIL AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION WE AREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE THANK
YOU. BY ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TO ME
START WITH SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CHAPTER OF CLIMATE REALITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND LINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
KAREN MCNAMARA I AM THE FOUNDER
AND CEO OF CONSCIOUS CONTAINER
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. BY AN
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON
BEHALF OF FULL AND PART. THERE
IS NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS GET UP.
OKAY HI LET'S NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
WE HAVE ANY- ANYONE WHO IS A
REGISTERED TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AND IS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN PERSON HE
WANTED PHONE LINES LIKE TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
MODERATOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- TO SHOW EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE SIX TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE ARE GETTING NOBODY
QUEUEING UP AT THIS TIME OKAY
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING THE BILL
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THOUGHTS
SILVA CASKEY. ASM I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE MATTER OF FORD I KNOW
PEOPLE THERE THAT HAVE
TESTIFIED OR SUPPORT. I WANT TO
CLARIFY FOR THE CHAIR SAID MY
EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY BILL IS BEING
AMENDED SO THAT TECHNICALLY.
ALL THE CURRENT BOTTLE BILL
WOULD PUT BE DISSOLVE BIRTH IS
BEING AMENDED TO CARRY THROUGH.
MATCH COM ARBORISTS- REDUCE
PORTIONS OF IT TO THE EXTENT OF
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY- SIDE
AS WELL AS A DOCTOR WOODS
BACKDROPS OF THOSE THOSE
ELEMENTS ARE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE ARE COMING FOR
COMMITTEE NEXT NEXT WEEK THAT
THE AMENDMENT WILL ALLOW. THE
REUSABLE OF PORTION TO GO
THROUGH IN THIS I'VE DISCUSSED
WITH THE AUTHOR THE OTHER SHE'S
VISITED OR AGAIN AS THE CHAIR
HAS AN IS I HAVEN'T LOOKED AT
THE REUSABLE- BOTTLE PORTION OF
IT AND- THE OTHER THIRTY NINE.
EXETER. PRODUCER- PROGRAMS AT
THEIR THROUGH THE WORLD ALL
HAVE A REVIEWS BOTTLE PORTION
OF IT TOO SO IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
ANYTHING STRANGE BUT BECAUSE OF
WHERE WE HEAR IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY BRINGING THAT BACK IN
AND I HAVE A BILL THAT WOULD.
WOULD SHIFT RESPONSIBILITIES TO
THE MANUFACTURERS WE WANT TO BE
CERTAIN THAT EVERYBODY THAT
KNOWS. ON THIS- CONCERN ABOUT
THE CITY'S PORTION WILL
CONTINUE AS IT DOES. ALL OVER
THE WORLD- AND I APPRECIATE DE
AMENDMENTS SAY SEE THAT THERE'S
SOME TECHNICAL. CONCERNS IT
WILL HAPPEN I REMOVED THE BILL.
OKAY I'M SURE THE FAN OF THE
BILL I YOU KNOW WE WERE THERE
AT THE BIRTH OF THIS BILL AND
AN ORGAN TOGETHER AND- AS SOON
AS WE AS WE GOT TO EXPLORE THIS
REALLY EXTRAORDINARY PRETTY AND
INVENTIVE FUND PROGRAM THEY
HAVE. I IN OREGON WHERE YOU
KNOW ALL THESE BEER
MANUFACTURERS GET TOGETHER AND-
WASH THE BOTTLES AND REALLY
REUSE THEM AND- THEY WORKS
REALLY WELL AND IN FACT IF THE
INTERESTING THING IS WE
ACTUALLY VISITED A WINERY. THAT
WAS USING THE THEY THEY THEY
DECIDED TO SIGN UP AND OF
COURSE THEY HAD TO USE THE BEER
BOTTLES TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM BECAUSE
EVERYTHING IS STANDARDIZED THE
WHOLE POINT IS YOU'RE USING.
THE EXACT SAME. BOTTLES AND
THEN THE TO SLAP THEIR OWN
LABELS ON. MON AND THE YOU KNOW
IT'S CERTAINLY A SMALLER BOTTLE
THAN A TRADITIONAL WINE BOTTLE
BUT THEY FOUND THAT NOT ONLY
WAS IT. GREAT FOR THEM TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM BUT
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T WANT A
FULL BOTTLE OF WINE RIGHT THEY
WANT THE SMALLER BOTTLES. AND
IT TURNS OUT THAT THE BOTTLE
CAP SEALS IT JUST AS WELL. AS A
CORK. SO THERE'S REALLY NO- HI
THIS YEAR THERE'S NO HALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT WITH
KEEPING. YEAH THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S CORRECT SO DAVE SO IF WE
COULD DO SOMETHING SIMILAR HERE
AND COMPANIES CAN PARTICIPATE
IT'S A WAY OF- WHILE GLASSES
HELP HIGHLY RECYCLABLE
MATERIAL. THE COURSE IT'S
NATURAL MATERIAL. I'M THERE'S A
LOT OF ENERGY GOES INTO
RECYCLING AND I MEAN YOU KNOW
THE- NO I'M I'M- REALLY
SUPPORTER CLASS BUT DID KNOW
I'VE- NEVER BEEN DOWN TO
MODESTO AND WATCH THE PHOTO
GALLO MELTDOWN THE GLASS AND
THE AMOUNT ON THE CULLITON
TURNED INTO NEW BOTTLES- YOU
WILL WE REALIZE PRETTY QUICKLY
HOW MUCH. HOW ENERGY INTENSIVE
A PROCESS THAT IS- THEY GOTTA
GET REAL YOU GET THAT REAL
THOSE FURNACES GET VERY HOT.
AND IF THERE'S A WAY FOR US TO
GET A LOT MORE LIFE OUT OF
THESE BOTTLES JUST BY WATCHING
THEM- ABSOLUTELY HI STANDARDS
ETCETERA. WE ARE THE WE MIGHT
AS WELL AND SO I'M I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR- OF YOUR
BILL AND- MISTER CHAIR IT'S NOT
LOST ON THE PRODUCERS OF GLASS
BOTTLES THAT THEY'RE A COVERED
ENTITY UNDER CAP AND TRADE SO
IS THE COST OF BY PARTICIPATING
IN THE IN THE AUCTION A
CAPTURED CLOSE UP THAT COSTS IS
ALSO GOOD TO GO UP SAID THIS IS
AN ALEC AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT. PROVIDE US WITH
BEVERAGES TO SHIFT TO ANOTHER
DAY THE PRICES ARTIFICIALLY LOW
AT NINETEEN DOLLARS A METRIC
TON BUT THAT'S THAT'S NOT TO BE
DEBATED DURING THIS BILL BUT
THIS ISN'T THIS IS EVERYBODY
WHO'S WHO'S WATCHING
UNDERSTANDS THAT THIS ISN'T A
WAY FOR THEM TO GET OUT OF THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM IF
THEY'RE- HAVING A REUSABLE
BOTTLE. SO STAY TUNED FOR ITS
ABSOLUTE RIGHT IN WITH THAT IN
MIND I. BECAUSE I KNEW THE
BILL'S COMING MY COMMUNITY
STATE OFF BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. MOVING
FORWARD IF THAT'S AT ALL
POSSIBLE NEED TO BE A
COOPERATIVE THANK YOU VERY I DO
REMEMBER. IT'S HARD A LOT
FASTER OKAY SO THE BILL'S
REMOVE ETCETERA CASKEY IF YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR AND
CREATE A PROJECT THAT. THE
OPENNESS SOME FOR MY COLLEAGUES
TO FOR THIS THIS IMPORTANT IS A
POLICY. I'M NOT GOING TO JINX
THE FLOW OF THIS I'M GOING TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR- SECRETARY BUGS CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER NINE A. B. NINE SIX TWO
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SENATOR
COME LONGER- THE MOTION ISTO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN. HI HOW AND I'D BATES HI
EIGHT HI DOLLY. DOLLY I
GONZALEZ SKINNER STERN Y.
CASKEY HI ASKI I'D- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY ARE WE KNOW HOW
OUR FRIEND DISORDER CHEN WHO'S
HERE TO I A LET MEMBERS I'D
ACTUALLY BEEN BELIEVE ARE THIS
IS OUR BILL- SO. YUP THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS ARE REALLY
PERSONAL TIME FIRST LIKE TO
START OFF BY PUTTING ALL THE
MINUTES FROM THE TWENTY MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU ALSO LET ME 2%
EIGHTY TWELVE SIXTY ASSEMBLY
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IS LEADING THE EFFORT TO BRING
THE FIRST HYDROGEN AND BATTERY
POWER TRAIN. TO NORTH AMERICA
AB TWELVE C. WITH BUILD A
CRITICAL IN FOR IS THE ZERO
TRAIN THIS WILL HELP THE STATE
SCHOOL REDUCE EMISSIONS ARE
MOVING TO CLEANER WERE OP BY
OUR NEW THE CLEANER DEADLINE
THIS LEGISLATION ON B. TWO
EIGHTY AUTHORED BY SO SCOTT
WIENER WHICH WAS A LAW YEAR
BETTER EXEMPTS FROM C. QUOTE
HYDRANT FUELING STATION FOR
BUSES NO AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE
CLUED FUELING STATIONS FOR
RAILS. THE FIRM WILL HELP THE
SAFE FOR. MORE EQUITY AND MORE
SO. TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
QUICKLY AND COST EFFECTIVELY
WITH ME I HAD THE HAILING
EXCUSE ME TWENTY HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF SAN MARIN COUNTY.
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY- WHICH
WILL BE A PRIMER WHAT IS FOR AB.
TWELVE SIXTY. GREAT LET'S GO TO
YOUR BILL AT THE THIRTY ONE
ASSISTS. TWENTY HUNTER WHO
THEIR. WE NOW DO WE HAVE THEM.
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR MR I'M
LOOKING FOR DELANEY HUNTER
THAT'S RIGHT YEAH YES MISTER.
THIS IS SAID SPEAK THE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE SIXTY THIS ITEM ELEVEN.
OUR PARISHES HAVING TROUBLE
GETTING THROUGH OKAY WHY DON'T
WE GO IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WANT
TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWELVE SIXTY ON THE PHONE LINES
AND WE'LL WE'LL JUST KEEP GOING
UNTIL WE CAN GET OUR ON. ON THE
LINE. ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO
VOICE SUPPORT. THE FIRST ONE
FILED BY ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT.
I THINK. OKAY I JUST GOT A NOTE
THAT. IF SHE'S CALLING ANOTHER
WRONG NUMBER I'M SORRY I TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI. ARM I'M
SORRY MR WOULD BILL WHERE WE
HONOR THIS IS AB TWELVE SIXTY
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI TWELVE SIXTY PLEASE PRESS
STAR ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO. TO WELL ONE
PERSON QUEUED UP TO CONSOLES
OUGHT THE FINAL REMINDER OUT TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWELVE
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHEN. OKAY MORE
TROUBLE OUR LIVES SO IN N. IS A
TWENTY HUNTER I'D STILL
UNAVAILABLE. YES SIR OKAY-
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED UP
WITH I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE FOR
INTERRUPTING BUT WE DID HAVE
ONE PERSON QUEUE UP I WONDER IF
THAT. HER BUT LET'S HOPE LET'S
GO CHECK THAT PERSON OUT. WHY
ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OPERATOR. YOUR YOUR OPEN MIND
ONE THIRTY. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER BURST APOLOGIZED AS
TECHNOLOGY GLITCH THE SYSTEM
ANY. ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WE ARE
THE SPONSORS OF S. B. EXCUSE ME
AB TWELVE SIXTEEN. AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. RIGHT YEP THOSE
WHO QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR
OKAY- FANTASTIC OKAY AND THEN
DO WE SO HOW ABOUT- OPPOSITION
I KNOW THERE IS ONE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION OPPOSITION- BUT
THAT BEING SAID IF FUNDS. YOU
KNOW BOB AS HE WERE ALSO
WAITING FOR DO ANY HUNTER BUT
BUT DOES ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES I DON'T SEE
ONE IN HERE PERSON. I WAS DOING
YEAH. FILAMENTS YOU WANT TO
SPEAK. FOR OKAY THAT WAS IT.
I'M SORRY I SOME OUTSIDE SHE'S
GOING TO TESTIFY OKAY ALL RIGHT
FIVE ANYONE OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR. A BI- TWELVE
SIXTY. AND NOBODY'S KILLING
THAT MR MILLER OKAY GREAT ART
SORRY BUDDY LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. MY PLEASURE YOU'RE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS. I'M
WHICH I THINK THAT IS A PLACE
RELEASE IS GONNA BE SOME PUBLIC
SOME OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
INPUT IF PEOPLE DO HAVE
CONCERNS OBVIOUSLY THE BOARD
CAN STILL GO AHEAD MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISION BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THERE'D BE SOME
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITY TO
RAISE CONCERNS IF THEY EXIST
WITH REGARDS TO THE PROJECTS
THAT MIGHT BE- IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL SO. WITHOUT I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO HELP SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. OTHER THOUGHTS QUESTIONS
CONCERNS IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DOLLY. THREE NINE ARE
WE WILL LET YOU CLOSE. ERA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER
THANK YOU GINGER. OKAY. FIVE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
I AM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWELVE
SIXTY BY SOMEBODY MEMBER CHEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN HI ALAN I
BATES ALL RIGHT BATES AYE DOLLY
DALY AYE GONZALEZ. SKINNER
STERN STERN IOWA CASKEY BY CAL
SKI I. THIS IS THE THIRD WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT LED ME
TO MY BILL IS SIX ASAL. DEAL
WITH AND THEN WE WILL BELIEVE
IT OPEN THE FOLKS DOWN ON OUR
WHEN WE A MOTION TO FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. REMOVE BY THE
VICE CHAIR- THERE ARE THREE
ITEMS OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS. CONTROL PLEASE CALL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
NUMBER SEVEN TEN AND TWELVE
ALAN HI ALAN I'D BATES HI BATES
HI DALLI DALLI I GONZALEZ
SKINNER STERN ALL RIGHT STERN
IOWA CASCADE BY CAL SKI I.
INTERESTED ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW
GO TO THAT'S AND SO IT'S LIFT
THE CALLS ON THE VARIOUS BILLS
AND START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
THIS IS ROBERT REDUCES AB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR. BOB HAS ADDED OKAY
SO SOME OF THESE BILLS REMOVE
SOME HAVEN'T I HAVEN'T KEPT
TRACK SO. IF YOU NEED TO MOTION
PLEASE LET ME KNOW BUT I
BELIEVE THAT WHEN. THIS AS
BUSINESS WAS MOVED BY CENTER
CASKEY. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS- THE VOTE IS TWO TO ONE
WITH ALLEN VOTING I AM BATES
VOTING NO. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER. DALLI DALLI NO
GONZALEZ. SKINNER STERN- STERN
I. THREE OKAY WE'RE WE'VE GOT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS THAT ON
LET'S GO TO ITEM. AB THREE ITEM
NUMBER TO MAYBE THREE SIXTY
THREE THIS ONE DOES REQUIRE
MOTION I'M ALMOST CERTAIN THIS
IS CENTER SAYS OWNER MEDINA IS
BILL. MOVED BY SENATOR DOLLY.
MARKETS ON PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I AM NUMBER TWO AB THREE SIX
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION- ALLEN HI ALAN
I'D BATES RIGHT BATES HI DALLI.
DALLI I'D GONZALEZ SKINNER
STERN- AYE STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI
AYE AYE CASKEY AYE. OKAY MOVIE
THAT OPENED THAT'S GOOD I'M
THREE AB FOR EIGHTY BY CARILLO-
ONCE AGAIN I BELIEVE WE CAN GET
IT WE HAVE WE HAVE A MOTION WE
HAVE A MOTION OKAY I'M SORRY.
LET'S SEND THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S
ANOTHER AND THAT'S RIGHT YOUR
CITED TO VOTE FOR IT YEP YOU
DID OKAY SO THE RATE THAT
YOU'RE IN THE MEASURE BUT I ON
THIS ONE I LET'S LET'S. CALL
THE ROLL ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. THE
TEARS VOTING I THE VICE CHAIRS
VOTING I'D VOTERS. TO ZERO.
DALLY DALLIED NO CAN. SKINNER
STERN. AYE STERN AYE Y. CAO SKI
HI MY CASKEY I. OKAY LET'S NOW
GO TO WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN
AGAIN LET'S COULD ITEM FOR THIS
AB SEVEN THIRTEEN BY CRISTINA
GARCIA. IN SOME WAYS COLOR OFF
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN BY SOME A MEMBER
GARCIA. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE VOTE IS ONE TWO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR OF STAINING DALLY.
DALLIED NO GONZALEZ SKINNER. HI
SKINNER AYE STERN ALL RIGHT
STERN HI WHY CASKEY BY MY COUNT
SKI HI. ARE WE WILL. I GUESS
WE'RE GONNA CLOSER ON THAT ONE
BECAUSE- SENATOR. YES FORTY TWO
CENTER SKINNER SAID CENTER
GONZALEZ NOT COMING TODAY IS
THAT RIGHT OKAY SO WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE ON. THAT ITEM
ITEM FOR THAT'S FOR TO VOTE I'D
LET'S NOW GO TO AB FIVE SEVEN
FIFTY THREE OUT OF FIVE THIS IS
TIM GRAYSON SPELL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PLEASE. CONSULT PLEASE
KALRA ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SEVEN
FIFTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
NOW WITH THE AT THE VOTERS TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND THE VICE CHAIR OF STAINING.
DALLY DALLI NO GONZALEZ SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN HI.
FORTY TWO OKAY THAT'S FORTY TWO
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON AN
ITEM LET'S GO TO ITEM SIX IS A
AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEAVES BILL THIS BILL
DOES REQUIRE A MOTION. MOVED BY-
SENATOR STERN. CONSUMERS
CULTURAL ITEM NUMBER SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NEAT AT LEE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION ALAN HI ALAN I BATES
BATES NO DALLI DALLI NO
GONZALEZ SKINNER. HI SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STERN I Y. CAO
SKI MY CASKEY I. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL CLOSER ON THAT ITEM WHEN
WE REOPEN THE ROLE IN THE
THAT'S FORTY TWO WILL WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN THAT AND
THAT'LL- THAT'S NOT GOING OVER
TO APPROPRIATIONS I BELIEVE
THAT'S NOW GONE WHEN WE RE OPEN
THE ROLE WITH THE CALL ON THE-
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEVEN BILLION.
WITH. FIFTY THREE OVER THE IBM
WITH THE CALL ME I'M SORRY WITH
ONE. OKAY THE EIGHT EIGHT
SECOND AGO. I THINK IT IS BE
JOURNAL OF WE DID WE DID.
SOMEONE I THINK STILL A MOTION
EX WHAT WOULD CAST DID YOU VOTE
FOR MY. YOU DID THAT'S RIGHT.
I'VE SEEN RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY YOUR. IT HAS WAS THE
FOURTH LINE OKAY SWARCLIFFE I
THAT I AM SEVENTH THE CRISTINA
SPOTS FOUR TO ONE VOTE AND I
NUMBER FIVE AB FIFTY TWO
GRAYSON TO FOR ONE VOTE AS WELL
ALL RIGHT LET'S I LIVE TO CALL
ON CAN CALENDAR. GOOD SOMEONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CONSENT.
CONSENT ITEMS ARE SEVEN TEN AND
TWELVE- WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE BATES VOTING AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I'D. BECAUSE IN ORDER
TO HANDLE GONZALEZ GARY- THAT
WILL CALDERON AND IT'S A SIX
ZERO VOTE OKAY WE'LL CLOSE THE
ROLE ON THE KITCHEN COUNTER
LET'S NOT GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN STILL THIS IS AB. EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
CONTROL PLEASE COLORADO. AND A
NUMBER EIGHT AB EIGHT NINE
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER.
THE CHAIR VOTING II THE VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING- BATES. BATES
NOT VOTING DALLI. DALLI NO.
SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN. OKAY
WE WILL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR
STERN LET'S GO TO COME AB SICK
TWO. IT WAS THAT WE HAVE A FOR
CO AUTHORS ALREADY FOR THE CAN.
BIPARTISAN IT'S ALWAYS COLOR
OFF ITEM NO NINE A NIGHTS TWO
BY SOME BESIDE COME LONGER. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THAT FIRST AMENDMENT REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING HI
GONZALEZ SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
STERN. I WILL HAVE TO. STERN'S
STEPPED UP PERCENT WILL HAVE TO
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR THAT AS
WELL LET'S GO TO CHEN THIS IS
AB TWELVE SIXTY ITEM ELEVEN.
IT'S ALWAYS KALRA ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWELVE SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN THE MOTION
IS. TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
BOTH VOTING II. GONZALEZ
SKINNER. SKINNER I STERN
RESTAURANTS ALREADY VOTED IN
VERY VOCAL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
THAT. NOW LET'S GO BACK UP TO
THE FIRST THREE ITEMS SO THAT
CENTER SKINNER CAN ADD ON ITEM
ONE THIS IS A B. TWO EIGHTY
FOUR BY ROBERT RIVAS. I THE
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST REFER AS
AMENDED REAP SKEWS ME. DO
PASSES AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
CHAIR VOTING I'D VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING NO. GONZALEZ SKINNER
SKINNER FIVE. OKAY LET'S GO TO
MEDINA IS CO THAT WILL WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN THE B. TWO
EIGHTY FOUR THAT'S GOING TO
MEDINA IS BILL AB THREE SIXTY
THREE. I ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
THREE SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION. WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING II.
GONZALEZ SKINNER INNER I OKAY
WILL CALL THE ROLL ON ON ITEM
TO LOOK GOOD I AM THREE THIS IS
AB FOUR EIGHTY BY CARILLO.
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS ARE
CONSUMERS KALRA. I AM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY BY
SOME REMEMBER CARILLO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING HI. GONZALEZ
SKINNER. SKINNER HI. I WILL
CLOSE ROLE THAT I THINK I THINK
THAT MEANS THAT CENTERS BATES
AND SKINNER ARE ALL SET LET'S
OPEN THE ROLE FOR NINETY NINE
CENTS. I ORDERS ON ALL. JUST IN
CASE DO ITEM EIGHT THAT'S ABA
NINETY SEVEN MULLIN. YES YOU'RE
GOOD YOUR HONOR THING I THINK A
GOOD THING THIRTY THREE TO
THIRTY MINUTES IN. I'LL TELL
OPEN TO MEET THE IS A- AB EIGHT
SEVEN MY MULLIN. ASSEMBLY COLOR.
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
EIGHT NINE SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MALL AND THE
MOTION IS DUE HAS FIRST BE
REFERRED TO VOMITING ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER VICE CHAIR
VOTING I'D MAYBE. AB SORRY
CHAIR VOTING I'VE VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. GONZALEZ STERN AYE
STERN AYE. ECONOMY YEAH. PART
THAT WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THAT'S GONNA GO TO NATURAL
RESOURCES- SO LOCAL ADDRESSED
THERE LET'S GO TO ITEM D. B.
NINE SIXTY TWO BY COLOR ITEM
NINE. CONSULTAS COLOR. I
REMEMBER NINE AB NINE SIX TWO
BY SENATOR COM LAGER MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST THE
MAN REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS GONZALEZ.
STERN ALL RIGHT STERN HI. ALL
RIGHT WITH CLOSER ON THAT I
THINK THAT MEANS WE'VE GOT ALL
OUR VOTES AT. CONSULTANTS IS
THAT CORRECT. YES OKAY. ARE
WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN THIS
HEARING AND- WE HAVE. MORE TO
COME BUT- BUT THE THIS MEETING
OF THE TWENTIETH OF JUNE IS
HEREBY ADJOURNED.